is it possible let's say that there
we're entertaining a theory
in which there's physical stuff maybe
conscious states are are in a separate
some kind of a separate system obviously
they're related and then there's an
abstract system maybe that's where the
laws of physics resides or something
can is there
are each of these
equally
fundamental so is it possible that we
could dispense with the abstract stuff
it might be it might be like there's a
theory here i think it's called what's
it called
i forget what it's called but it's
something like you know the laws of
physics are ideas in the mind of god so
maybe all we have is you know physical
stuff and mental stuff
and you know the mental is more
fundamental and you don't need the
abstract stuff
can you dispose with the physical stuff
i actually think you can i think it's
conceivably possible to tell the
idealist story which says that
everything is mental everything is an
experience everything is an idea i don't
take that position but it's at least
conceivably possible that
this the most basic story we tell about
the physical world is wrong
is it possible to dispense with the
existence of consciousness and conscious
mental states i would say no
that one there's there's no
true story that we could tell that is
possibly true in which
our conclusion is consciousness doesn't
exist
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i have the great pleasure of
sitting today with steve patterson who
you may well not know
but you can find him at
stevedashpatterson.com
you may also want to check out his
podcast which is called patterson in
pursuit am i correct about that steve
indeed yep well welcome to dark horse
hey thanks for having me
so you are an independent philosopher
which uh
independent and philosopher would both
be pursuing as terms here but let's just
say that's a fascinating category to me
i take philosophy very seriously as a as
a tool for getting logic
uh correct
and
i also find the idea of someone doing
this independently very tantalizing
i will say for my audience's benefit i
became aware of you when i read an essay
that you wrote
recently
on a topic that is near and dear to my
heart you wrote about the question of
whether or not we are in
a dark age and i don't know how long i
have been arguing that we are in a dark
age i know that when i searched my
twitter feed that my references to it go
back to 2009 when i signed up for
twitter so it goes back at least that
far
but in any case it's a it's a claim that
i have made to people and mostly i get
blank stares how could this possibly be
a dark age given all of the marvelous
technology around us the parents that we
are so scientific so in any case i was
fascinated by your essay and i felt it
was important that we talk about this
very interesting topic great i can't
wait thanks for inviting me on this is
also a topic near and dear to my heart
for what it's worth i'll give you the
the brief story here so
i was interested many years ago and i
started my intellectual journey in
political theory and economics which
seems very far away from philosophy but
i realized after a few years of
researching political theory that a lot
of my assumptions were coming from the
domain of economics and then after
studying economics i realized there were
questions in the methodology of
economics that i found
really really important like there are
different ways to come to
economic conclusions
you could go out in the world you can
make a bunch of testable predictions and
maybe figure out how the world works
economically that way maybe you sit in
an armchair and make deductions maybe
that's the right approach to figure out
economic knowledge and i realize
questions of economic methodology are
really philosophy it's really just the
epistemology of
economics and then that sucked me into
the philosophy world i said okay well
i'm not no longer just interested in how
we discover economic knowledge how do we
know any knowledge generally how do we
make any claims about anything is there
any truth at all and if so how could we
arrive at it
and so that's how i got sucked into the
philosophy domain was actually through
politics and economics it wasn't because
i've been a lifelong philosopher
actually i have a
a parallel story which is i i wasn't
especially interested in
philosophy in fact i was uh frustrated
by it for the most part until
i became interested in evolutionary
biology which has two branches there's
adaptive evolution which is the part i'm
interested in but in order to do
adaptive evolutionary thinking well
you have to have a proper phylogeny so
you know which creatures are related to
which other creatures and in what way
and then you can describe the patterns
of adaptations that have emerged on that
tree but the problem is there are
intense philosophical debates about what
the right way to construct those trees
interesting might be and so i started to
take it seriously and the more i did
that
the more i realized that actually it
wasn't just phylogeny that depended on
this it was your ability to think about
anything clearly dependent on your
understanding of the
the the philosophical
um
uh
dependencies that allow logic to work or
cause it to fail right if you don't
you don't have to know them explicitly
but you do have to do it right or it
doesn't work
our first sponsor for this episode is
all form a company that makes terrific
custom sofas
we like them so much we have two of them
what makes this sofa so terrific for a
fraction of the cost of traditional
sofas you can customize size layout
fabric and color they do arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an 8 seat
sectional this is the easiest way to
customize a sofa and the quality is
fantastic furthermore they are beautiful
and comfortable roomy and adaptable
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your home free and fast and assembly is
easy
we started with a beautiful sectional
all-form sofa in whiskey leather it's
soft and supple and warm unlike a lot of
leather and we pile on it to watch
movies it's gorgeous and incredibly
comfortable a rare combo
we like it so much we got a second one
some of our listeners have asked if all
form holds up to pets why yes it does
the leather that all form uses is 20
thicker than typical furniture leather
and shows nowhere despite the fact that
both cats and the dog lie on the couch
many evenings
and if you prefer fabric all form
fabrics are three and a half times more
durable than the industry standard for
heavy duty fabrics
so their fabrics are going to hold up to
pets as well
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever and that's a long time
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
darkhorse
all form is offering 20 off all orders
to our listeners at allform.com
slash darkhorse step up your sofa game
today
our next sponsor is moiq that's moo plus
oink
an 8th generation farmer founded moiq
and is working hard to help save the
family farm and get its customers access
to the highest quality meat on any of
the inner planets whereas 97 of the
chickens served in the u.s are dipped in
a chlorine solution moink a family farm
will never do that
moink delivers grass-fed grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and wild-caught alaskan salmon direct to
your door
moik farmers farm like your grandparents
did and as a result moink meat tastes as
it should which is to say delicious
unlike the supermarket moink gives you
total control over the quality and
source of your food you choose the meat
delivered in every box from rib eyes to
chicken breasts to pork chops to salmon
fillets and much more
plus you can cancel at any time
we love everything about mike the fact
that the meat is grass-fed and finished
on small farms the lovely publications
that come along with it and of course
the meat itself
shark tank host kevin o'leary called
moink bacon the best bacon he'd ever
tasted we agree it's amazing
keep american farming going by signing
up at moicbox.com
darkhorse and listeners of this show
will receive free filet mignon for a
year that's one year of the best filet
mignon you'll ever taste but for a
limited time
spelled moiq
m-i-o-n-k-box dot com slash darkhorse
that's moicbox.com
darkhorse our final sponsor for this
episode is vivobarefoot shoes made for
feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be and be
constrained by
vivos are made by people who know feet
these shoes are a revelation
here at dark horse we love these shoes
they are beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolved to
walk move and run barefoot but modern
shoes that are overly cushioned and
strangely shaped have negatively
impacted foot function and are
contributing to a health crisis one in
which people move less than they might
in part because their shoes make their
feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up
foot strength increases by 60 in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them
the number of people wearing vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
vivo barefoot has a great range of
footwear for kids and adults for every
activity from hiking to training as well
as everyday wear
they're a certified b corp pioneering
regenerative business practices
and their footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild on it
go to vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get
an exclusive twenty percent off
additionally all new customers get a
hundred day free trial to see if you
love them as much as we do that's v i v
o b a r e f o o t
dot com slash darkhorse
right right i like to think of it as you
have to be able to do a rigorous
conceptual analysis for any discipline
so under it doesn't really matter what
the discipline is you're going to find
there are going to be
ultimately philosophical questions about
the core concepts of that discipline
what exactly is a cell anyways like what
exactly is life
and are we sure about what the
definition is how did we arrive at that
knowledge could we be wrong
it doesn't matter what the discipline is
you're going to find those those core
concepts have to be examined which i
thought was
sort of obvious like i sort of
intuitively thought that was obvious but
then as i've researched different
domains i realized
that is not only is it
seemed to be not obvious people are
allergic to it and i think it's like
it's shocking and preposterous to step
back and try to do the deep conceptual
analysis of things like actually
i worked in the non-profit world briefly
at a non-profit that was focused on
economics teaching
economic theory let's say to young
people
and in this job i was talking with
professors who i had assumed had already
sorted out questions of economic
methodology where i was like okay these
are already professionals you know they
have the formal training i was very
naive and i thought like when i would
talk to them you know bring up some of
these interesting questions to hear what
their resolutions were they didn't it's
not even that they had bad ideas they
didn't have any models at all they had
no epistemology of their own domain and
i thought oh my gosh this is a scandal i
can't believe this and then to my shock
and horror as i've researched other
domains i found the exact same pattern
because nobody like people don't seem to
be asking these types of questions
yeah it's i i don't want to say every
domain because i think there might be
one important exception not a domain but
a
temporal phenomenon that excludes a
domain temporarily okay but i do think
that in general this is the truth of
almost every domain almost all the time
okay well so i do want to ask you about
that so so uh
what is what is the exception here
because i'll tell you from my experience
prior to investigation
i would have intuitively thought there
are a couple of areas which
uh couldn't possibly be making the same
uh oversights and that would be number
one would be mathematics and there was
another one less confidently i thought i
thought was physics that the
mathematicians and the physicists are
supposed to be the most rigorous of all
surely they are
engaging seriously with their conceptual
frameworks and then i found
that's not the case that even even in
math what seems to be the purest of all
like pure logical deductions
they're not they have not established a
bunch of critical concepts stretching
back it turns out for at least a century
there are there and i'd love to talk
about this in more detail maybe later
but at least a century you've got
ongoing critical foundational crises
that are not resolved even by the
mathematicians so i thought even if the
mathematicians are are
polluted by this there's there's no
refuge but you think there is well
there's an exception first of all i do
uh i want to i want to plead the case
for the mathematicians i think you can
find yourself um much more forgiving of
their foolishness if you realize that
they are apes right
they may be mathematicians but they are
apes doing math right and we'll see
they're doing all right that conclusion
yeah no that's true when i say that
though people go that is about the most
defensive thing you could possibly say
but uh when you say because you're a
biologist you're making a technical
claim i agree i agree okay yeah i mean
it's also a a
a ruthless accusation about them um
which i hope they will take personally
but uh yeah no it's also a technical a
technical claim about about phylogeny
again
um
yeah all right so my my um
my exception to the rule
that
everybody is really confused about the
fundamentals of
the the work they think they are
contributing to
is
um
a field
in the process
of
enlightenment
i believe may temporarily
have
insight i don't think it's global but i
think that fields when they are actually
in the process of
uh
so my model for this involves
you have some sort of a
uh an insight that kicks loose
some it opens a landscape right there's
some landscape of truths that nobody
knows and then somebody comes up with an
insight that opens the door to that
landscape and there's a flurry of
important work that follows
that flurry of important work is a
temporary state
but it is a very different state than
the hunting around for the next insight
that opens the next landscape and so i
guess what i would say is i find
my colleagues in evolutionary biology
much more confused than
their immediate ancestors seemed to be
okay well this is gonna get to some big
questions okay
so
do you say this based on your experience
talking with their immediate ancestors
are based on reading the work of the
immediate ancestors and flying at higher
quality that is a great
a great question and it has a very uh
unfortunately not simple answer i knew
because evolutionary biology is a
basically brand new field right starts
in 1859 so very very new stuff
uh and because
it had a heyday in
the early to mid 20th century
i knew some of the greats
i didn't know them all right many were
gone before i ever got there but i knew
some of the grades
and they did seem to me
exquisitely clear-headed compared to the
descendant generation okay this is
fascinating this is a live ongoing
question i don't have an answer to
because i have heard people like
yourself and a few others that talk
about their
uh their education and maybe their
interaction with the greats and they
they seem to think
that there was a genuine intellectual
rigor there but i've never seen it
because that worked i'm too too many
generations removed so i have had one
hypothesis which is what what happened
is with the invention of the internet
it allowed
uh information to flow
such that
it looks like orthodoxies right now are
a lot um
more cacophonous
but that's only because we have the
technology that allows the dissenting
voices to be heard
maybe it's the case
that the reason there seemed to be more
harmony a few generations ago is because
we didn't have the technology that
allowed dissenters to speak
well i'm not so another another way i
would say this is wouldn't you expect
that with the technology like the
internet we would see
the
the disassembly eventually of the great
structures of knowledge that were put by
there by the previous generation
well a i think there may be something
novel going on in the current moment
that this that we are actually looking
at
two problems one you've got the
influence that you've just described
where we we can tune into the noise and
i do believe that uh
cultural evolution
cultural content is always very noisy at
its inception and what makes culture
useful is uh selection so
basically what we what persists it tends
to be much wiser than the back and forth
by a lot
um so there's also a a lindy effect here
with respect to the ancestors right the
ancestors who whose work
stands the test of time strike us as the
greats of the past whereas people we
might have thought were the greats of
the past that have been dispensed with
because they turned out to be mostly
wrong they get forgotten so there's a
lot of different things that can cause
this illusion but here's the really
interesting data point that i have and i
only have one of them but wow is it
interesting to me
so i learned
from
three
great mentors
okay one of them was bob trivers he's
still alive
uh i still know bob i learned a ton i
was an undergraduate he was my advisor
of his uh
and
i learned from dick alexander who was
not as famous a person but was as
clear-headed a thinker as anybody in his
generation of evolutionary biologists he
was like a a dawkins-like figure um but
he was
uh
his sentences were so complex that i
think he just did not reach the audience
that dawkins did but anyways brilliant
guy
and i learned from dawkins who i never
met until 2018 but i learned because he
wrote so much and i was able to read his
books and they really resonated with me
and so i learned that he was the mentor
i'd never met
until 2018. okay when i did meet him
on stage and uh
we had an extensive interaction which
was only partially captured on video
unfortunately okay there's some of it is
available but some of it was lost
apparently to everyone
but what i found
was that he
had become confused about his own ideas
and this is not
he is an older guy but he's
mentally very sharp this was not a
question of him having you know
lost his capacity to think this was a
question of him having lost the courage
of his convictions so what i said to him
on stage actually was
that
i found him in conflict with himself
that his current ideas
were um defeated by his previous ideas
and i wanted him to just look at what
happens
when
you juxtapose them and this is sorry
this is specifically about a biological
concept yes okay the biological concept
of his own invention okay that's the
thing so richard dawkins is the inventor
of the concept of memes
right
and means you so
cultural evolution was it was understood
to exist but you really needed the
concept of memes to turn it into a
rigorous object to study
um
and what i found when i talked to him
about the meaning of cultural evolution
the meaning of memetic
adaptation
was that he viewed it
as
trivial
and
basically analogous to
genetic evolution but he did not
understand that it was actually
the potent force that made our species
capable of the unique
evolutionary tricks that it can do that
no other creature can do
right he sees
you know
the he sees happy birthday the song
right as a good example of how memes can
evolve
but it's an utterly trivial example he
doesn't understand that catholicism is a
much better example right that
catholicism and the way it evolves into
protestantism and that basically the
story of human evolution
is the story
of how the genes offloaded the heavy
lifting of adaptation to the software
layer and that that software layer and
the genetic
hardware layer
have a direct relationship it's not that
cultural evolution is like genetic
evolution cultural evolution is a means
to an end employed by genes to solve
problems the genes themselves cannot
solve
dawkins the inventor of the concept that
allows you to see that couldn't see it
which
yeah what is your explanation for that
well i think there are a couple things
that are true
i think one thing is that
nothing about evolutionary biology
is remotely politically incorrect i mean
is politically correct it is a
politically incorrect discipline that is
i mean it's not that it's it's not that
what it says is bad it's that's what it
says about humanity i say arbitrary i i
see and so the problem is a you know in
1976 when dawkins wrote the selfish gene
he was a young man he was a young gun
and he wasn't an established scientist
he didn't have a long publication record
he was a very gifted writer and he was a
very gifted thinker and he had that sort
of brash young man thing and he wrote a
brilliant book and it caught on and it
made him who he is right but the point
is as an established person with
something to lose
as an older person who isn't you know
brash and ready to go all in on these
concepts
uh i think he has
i mean some of the things he said to me
on stage were
thoughts that would be more
characteristic of stephen jay gould who
is like
the antithesis of richard dawkins
right they believed inverse things
and yet what i found dawkins saying on
stage were things that steven j gould
might have said and we're shocking
coming out of dawkins mouth and i
believe that part of that is about
uh
having been right and
uh
losing
the courage of those convictions because
of the danger of where it might lead
okay let me let me rip off this for a
little bit this is fascinating um
fascinating
so
it might be that part of what's going on
here
is
a high level of
let's say
conceptual ability
in specific domains
or even specific aspects of specific
domains might not port onto thinking
generally so let me let me be a bit more
specific
it could be the case that when you read
the work of richard dawkins you are
seeing
a an actually impressive
uh
idea structure
and then
we
make this inference that the impressive
idea structure comes from a mind that
must be
generally competent in creating these
idea structures
this is not just a one-hit wonder type
thing that there has to be a level of
skill
that we would expect would translate
into especially different claims within
that one domain like you would you would
say richard dawkins is a competent
biologist who would like to say that
because he wrote this incredible look
when i look over history i'm not sure
that's true
and i'm not sure it's the case that
being really really good on that one
thing
translates generally which is shocking
okay
this is this is beautiful because i
actually have in this i mean i hate to
do richard if you're watching i
apologize for analyzing you this way
but
here's the problem with what you just
said okay
the
disagreement between dawkins and me
centered around the question of what to
do
with
religion and things that behave like it
and
dawkins point dawkins is of course a
famous atheist and his point is this is
a mind virus
my point
when you know we we somehow i've
forgotten exactly how but we asked each
other on stage sort of well what do you
think and he said
mind virus or the equivalent
and i said
no
it's extended phenotype
now extended phenotype
is a richard dawkins concept which he
himself considers his most important
contribution to biology
okay that's his own assessment so
in addressing your hypothesis about what
might be going on my point is actually
the zone in which dawkins has to be
hyper-competent in order for him to see
what it is that i think should be right
in front of him okay is his area of
specialty more than anyone else is on
earth i love that point i was not
expecting that correction to go in that
direction but i love that point okay so
let me throw out a new uh a new theory
here again i don't i don't have the
answer to these questions i'm just
trying to come up with a
some plausible
theory for the information i'm taking in
okay
okay
here would be a more controversial point
is it the case then that there is a
genuine possibility that
uh excellent writers
are
maybe synthesizing concepts that they
don't themselves understand
so could it be the case that like when
you look at the history for example of
the theory of relativity did it
originate with einstein no
parts of it i mean a synthesis of it
was with einstein but there were little
parts uh here and there beforehand now
i'm not actually i think einstein is one
of the few
historical thinkers a few recent
historical thinkers who i'd say seem to
have
a lot of
uh general purpose conceptual skill
he was he was sort of aware of the
process of theorizing i think in a
respectable way that a lot of his
contemporaries weren't but but maybe
it's the case that
sorry i've nev i've never met richard so
it's is okay if i uh you know
speak off the cuff here but maybe it's
the case that that could be an example
of somebody sit putting
ideas together in a way that they
genuinely themselves don't understand
maybe that's what's going on i don't
think so and
i i think now i'm i'm putting together
all of the things that that um
happened surrounding this conversation
and i'm realizing that i might have the
answer that's what happened
um and it was almost
the way it unfolded was
very shocking
before
i went on stage with dawkins i was in
chicago and while i was in chicago i met
with jerry coyne who i'd also never met
all right he's another another great
from my field
and
i put a question to him
um
[Music]
so over breakfast i asked i asked jerry
kind i said i don't understand why it is
that
there has been no major theoretical
progress in our discipline since 1976
and this doesn't seem
to bother anyone
right that suggests we're doing
something wrong
and he said
something that astonished me i couldn't
believe i was hearing one of the greats
say this
what he said was
well
you know i think my generation that is
coins generation
got it all pretty well right and there
wasn't
a lot left okay so so i'm sorry continue
well that's only half the story so first
of all i used to believe that myself
when i started studying with bob trivers
i did feel like i'd been born too late
because i thought i was good at
evolutionary thinking but all the big
stuff had been done and it took me a
while to realize how many big questions
were completely unanswered
and you just didn't hear them very often
because the lack of progress had caused
people to learn to stop talking about it
right and it was like questions
big fundamental stuff was unanswered and
as soon as i figured that out
i knew what i wanted to do with my life
but i didn't see it immediately so coin
was sort of
uh
revisiting this idea that they had
gotten all the big stuff right and the
only things left were cleanup now here's
the part that blew my mind
on stage with dawkins i asked him the
question
why do you think
we haven't made any major theoretical i
mean you know you can ask an
evolutionary biologist what are the
great theoretical insights that we've
had since 76 and i there's no good
answer to that question right they don't
exist so i asked him that
he said the same damn thing
he said the same damn thing this is
somebody who
certainly has to understand that we do
not yet have a robust explanation for
you know we know why
a peacock has a fancy tail because the p
hens don't mate with them if they don't
we don't know why the p hens care right
we've got lots of ideas and we can all
name the ideas but nothing totally works
and i can tell you why they don't work
but never mind that the point is here i
am sitting with richard dawkins for the
second time in one day being told by one
of the greats in my field that his
generation answered all the big
questions and the lack of progress was
because we were done
and it's just like well
you know
yeah all right go ahead so so so you
take a
a young independent mind like myself who
has not met the greats as you've
described them i listen to that and i go
why would you call these people greats
how could you arrive at the conclusion
that somebody who believes we have
arrived at the final truth
on an extraordinarily complex topic is
is a great mind that seems like a very
very elementary error
you know and well here here's the thing
i mean i know that there's i'm going to
get you in trouble brett i'm sorry you
don't have to answer it you don't want
to if i if there was more trouble i
could get into i might be worried but
i've already gotten in trouble with
everybody here's the thing
dick alexander my phd advisor
would never in a million years have said
that right he he wouldn't have
formulated the thought and he would have
mocked anybody who did right
so i do think there's a there's at least
two types of what i'm calling the greats
and i guess the point is really they
need two different categories right
there are people who have accomplished
lasting things
who may or may not be
really good at it right
darwin was a great but apparently the
idea was also ready to pop right the
fact that wallace and darwin both had
the idea tells us that that one wasn't
going to wait very long right and it
happens that darwin was also
great at what he did this also happens i
would love to talk about this in the
history of mathematics maybe later same
thing happens cool well i'm very
interested in this this taxonomy because
i think it has a lot to say but it is
totally also possible for somebody to be
at the right place at the right time and
not really have extraordinary capacity
i don't think that could possibly be
true of dawkins he's and and really
dawkins is so good at synthesis
um that which i think is some is a
process we undervalue right we don't
even really talk about it as the
counterpoint to reductionism
right and we should because the point is
yes reductionism buys you something but
you don't leverage that something until
you synthesize it and figure out what
the real picture is right
um
so anyway
maybe i'm making excuses for the man or
maybe
my
my inkling is right that something
changed about his level of intellectual
courage
well let me ask you one more question on
this so you said you had an example of
somebody who you considered a grade who
would never make the claim that we
solved biology okay
so do you think that what was that
gentleman's name dick alexander dick
alexander okay do you think that dick
alexander would consider richard dawkins
a grade
knowing the claim
that
that you that you just said you know if
he were aware dawkins claimed that
biology is solved
what do you think he would say i think i
know exactly what he would say because i
think i had the conversation with him
okay
so that's the thing is you know it's not
a huge field and and the fact that all
of these greats of various kinds
co-existed and we knew them meant that
you sort of heard these conversations
and the thing is
a dick respected dawkins
and dawkins respected dick but i don't
think
dick certainly did not see
dawkins as
um
transcendent in some way right
he did see him as competent
very competent let's say um
you know and i think i think that's
probably what what uh
what dawkins would say of alexander also
um but you know the problem is you know
again back to the ape thing you know
biologists are also largely apes and um
largely
yeah i would like to hear the
accessibility there are some others but
all right all the ones i knew certainly
uh show that that evidence but
um
the
there is resentment of a guy like
dawkins because of you know you've got
all of these bright people
in a brand new landscape of ideas
figuring out how a whole different type
of biology works and making tons of
progress
and you have somebody like dawkins who's
very good at understanding it and very
good at explaining it and so he
disproportionately shows up on people's
on the public's radar yeah yeah um
because of his position which i think
did dawkins a disservice because his
real gift was synthesis which i believe
is actual science it's not
popularization synthesis is
as important as reductionism right and
the fact that dawkins was also good at
popularizing
uh got him dismissed too easily but
anyway dick respected him but i don't
think he uh i don't think he thought
dawkins was special except in his
ability to communicate which everybody
agrees is uh extremely good so i think
that is a
consistent pattern that we would see
across disciplines where the people that
the general public
and maybe
undergrad student undergrad students
would consider as grades
aren't
i think generally when you look closely
at different disciplines it looks like
there are a few
brilliant original minds
that are coming up with original
concepts doing doing interesting work
and then there is another type of mind
which is the
uh
the
articulator somebody that can skillfully
talk about the concepts uh you know do a
interview for
um pbs
that becomes uh uh
that that gets a the cultural
designation of this here as an
intellectual
and then and then problems are caused
from that moment because what what
happens is like there is a complex
social
phenomenon that happens where people
will start to take sides
and now it's now they're going to be
this is it seems to be within academia
as well they're going to be defenders of
the personality
and
critics of the personality and then
very shortly it is difficult to
carefully reason through ideas because
people start playing a social game
and now i mean the covet stuff was
incredible example of this right how
many people who took a very
strong position on either the vaccine or
ivermectin or whatever or do you think
we're genuinely sitting down on either
side and thinking through the concepts
carefully and how many were playing a
social game
i think that's the same type of
phenomenon that happens in in academia
as well
well it's interesting there's also
another dimension to what you're calling
the social game right there's a social
game that the the trivial destructive
version of it where you sort of jockey
for recognition without contribution
but the thing you know
it's interesting to talk about dick
alexander in this context because the
way you know
who alexander really was
was that he produced
a huge number of students and
to my knowledge
they all
um
[Music]
revere might be slightly too strong a
word but the respect that that group of
people holds for him
is
unparalleled right and it's really about
something he was
very much
he was very genuine he was very honest
about what he didn't know he gave
excellent feedback he
he
one of his rules was
you as student cannot work on what i'm
working on and it's not because i don't
want competition it's because i know
that if we work on the same thing it
will be inevitable that there's
ambiguity about what came from where and
i can't afford to have that with my
students so you're going to have to find
your own research program anyway he was
a brilliant mentor and the number of
people walking around who would tell you
the same thing about them is you know
it's it's dozens
um
so anyway he may be the unique
weird case but i guess my point is
as much as his name is obscure
his influence isn't because it came
through his students
and very often the cases where you're
talking about somebody who
[Music]
is the
you know the named great who might not
be one very frequently
their students
aren't so thrilled with them okay let me
challenge you yeah and and two we'll do
a short one and then a long one okay the
short challenge is um when you said that
you're identifying the man's greats
through the way that his students talk
about him
that's different than saying
identifying the the man's excellence by
the quality of his his students
work
so
are you also making the claim that their
work is very high very high quality well
the reason i didn't go that route is
because
not all of them
stayed in
the quality varies but i would say
uh nobody had anything like as high a
hit rate the number of very high quality
students that came out of that lab is
very large
okay so that's that is very interesting
i'm going to
talk for a minute if you'll give me a
little room for a monologue here this is
i guarantee this is going to be relevant
okay so we're going to talk about the
martial arts
okay so been very interested in martial
arts for a while
there's a lot of interesting parallels
between the martial arts and the world
of ideas um
history is very fascinating so i'm going
to tell an abbreviated story
prior to i think it was like
mid 20th century you had
the development of
a thousand different
schools of martial
thought technique and skill
you could broadly categorize them as
striking arts you can think of like
boxing as being a striking art
kickboxing and grappling arts like
wrestling jiu jitsu that type of thing
okay
what happened over in a martial arts
have been practiced for thousands of
years
but there was there did not seem to be
a
platform up until fairly recently for
excellent students of different
disciplines to fight each other
for whatever reason you had the jujitsu
practitioners and the judo practitioners
over slightly different different rules
you have in in the strikers you have
western boxing which is hands only
versus kickboxing which allows you know
kicks
versus uh muay thai which allows kicks
to the legs different role systems
so what you had was absolute masters
in their own disciplines who had a bunch
of students that said are
tai chi guy or maybe not tai chi that's
not that might be an exception but our
kickboxing guy is phenomenal he can
knock anybody out an exceptional martial
artist
everybody would rave about him you know
he's been he's been a
8th degree black belt for 30 years
then what started to happen in the
middle of the 20th century is there was
a there was a family called the gracies
in brazil that would that would conduct
vale tudo fights which is no holds
barred
they thought they had developed the
ultimate uh marshall style and they said
listen i don't care what you're how big
you are how long you've been training
where you are in the world you come to
brazil
and we'll fight you no holds barred and
we'll see who wins
it was a it was both a excellent
methodology for getting closer to the
martial truth and a great marketing
tactic because it's like hey what's
what's happening here so
the the abbreviated version is
the
uh this is called gracie jiu jitsu
announcement brazilian jiu jitsu
was totally revolutionary and dominated
a bunch of traditional martial arts that
had
the the super strong bodybuilders that
could knock anybody out it turns out
that grappling skill in a real vale tudo
context is way more important than
striking skill so even if you are
exceptionally gifted within the rules
and domains of kickboxing it it doesn't
even translate almost at all sometimes
to genuine martial skill okay so
this is uh by the way this is the
origins of the ufc i don't know if
you're familiar in mma there's this
organization called the ufc this had
their origins from the gracie family
because they said we want to have uh
mixed martial arts competition to
demonstrate the superiority of gracie
jiu-jitsu interesting historical tidbit
okay
one cool anecdote here um talking about
kickboxing i highly highly recommend
anybody watch this video if you're
interested in uh like psychology of when
an expert discovers that he is not as
skilled as he thought he was there's a
guy called rick rufus who was a
kickboxer i want to say in the 1980s
like absolutely phenomenal kickboxing
talent um
he was invited to participate in a
striking match with a muay thai guy
which this wasn't no it was no grappling
but muay thai muay thai allows leg kicks
and american
kickboxing which rick rufus came from
did not allow leg kicks so what happened
well at the beginning of the fight
uh rick looks impressive he's like doing
all these you know fancy moves he rocks
the guy okay and then the muay thai
practitioner discovers he has a
technique that the other guy is totally
unfamiliar with which is the leg kick
and so what does he do he keeps kicking
the leg he keeps kicking the leg and the
guy can't walk and eventually rick rufus
loses the fight
because he was
despite being a master you know a
international prize fighter
he had no experience with this technique
and so interesting i bring this up to
say he's interviewed about this and what
would you expect he says he goes well
you know kicking the leg doesn't take
any skill
as you would expect the person was like
okay well clearly
i built my whole psychology around being
a skilled martial artist here's a guy
who's smaller than me doing this fairly
simple technique that i had no i had no
ability to
counter and he beat me that's sort of
invalidates
me
and that implies all of the social
hierarchy around my dojo and all of the
conferences that i give i thought i was
an expert but when the rubber meets the
road i guess i'm not as good as i
thought okay that to me seems like
exactly the circumstance of
intellectuals and academics especially
over the course of the 20th century as
academia has grown
you have these different disciplines
that are hyper-specialized and you have
a bunch of prestige within the
discipline and the great teacher that
everybody reveres but it turns out
they're not actually conceptually
philosophically generally skilled and
when they're met with you know
interdisciplinary criticism they just
don't have the tools available to defend
themselves if you will okay now i think
i know what happened okay um and by the
way love the jiu jitsu analogy we'll
come back to um cool
what that means in a minute here but
here's what i learned from jerry coyne
and richard dawkins
[Music]
which is
the
arbitrary
reward structure
that exists in academia
awarded them something
which made them feeble in old age
they weren't necessarily feeble i can't
speak to coin as well but i can say
dawkins of 1976 really had what it took
to become a great i truly believe that
but
when you become successful in this
modality and that success brings you
into a realm where you now you're
dealing with only the cream of the crop
and everybody in the cream of the crop
crowd has the same situation which is
look if we start throwing punches
that could be bad so if we agree to kind
of pull our punches and be nice to each
other
yeah yeah you know we last and so the
point is i think what really happened to
richard dawkins
is that he escaped the zone of
competition that would have kept him
sharp
right and the thing that did not happen
to dick alexander was that never
happened to him because he collected
around him the best students in the
department who
you know they were all young guns who
would say whatever they thought needed
to be said there was no you know
etiquette about not you know attacking
an idea that dick had said right so the
point is he stayed sharp because he
surrounded himself with people who
didn't believe in those games and i
think what i really ran into with
dawkins was
that he he did not recognize i mean
maybe because i'm not young anymore i
was a young gun when i was young and now
i'm older but the point is i still
believe that my field is [ __ ] up
i still believe there are big
discoveries that are staring us in the
face that we are not uh seeking
um and he was not prepared because he
was telling himself the story that there
was no next generation of really good
biologists because he didn't need one
yeah he didn't recognize somebody who
knew some things he didn't know where he
should have been he should have been
fascinated by that and i was surprised
to find that he wasn't
okay this pattern is almost identical to
martial arts stuff like what just
just so people understand like when you
see a pattern that is
in wildly different areas and it's
pretty much the same pattern it's
valuable to
get a good model of what that pattern
looks like okay so this is what happens
in mars this is like a well-known thing
in the world of martial arts
people will get a some sort of you know
they'll get a black belt in karate or
something
and then they're curious they've seen
some of this jiu jitsu stuff so they go
you know they might maybe they practice
karate for eight years and they go into
the jiu jitsu gym
and they have they get their butts
handed to them by newbies
you know kids that are smaller than them
that have been training for a year and a
half
beat
the
sophisticated black belt that walks in
the door and then the and then they are
presented with the question do i
continue
to
get my butt handed to me by people that
clearly know something i don't or do i
say no you know it's not for me and i'm
gonna i'm gonna stick in my uh in the
area in which i'm skilled that is a that
is a well-known phenomenon it happened
to chuck norris that's an interesting
story he's like a real martial artist in
addition to being an actor and he was
skilled in striking arts the same thing
happened to him got destroyed by jiu
jitsu and said oh geez you know i'm
gonna stick around these people because
they're they're closer to truth than i
was so i think in that so you're sort of
describing the same phenomenon that he
had success and then he was presented
with a choice do i go back into the do i
go swim with the sharks again or do i
continue the the
path without that sharp competition
yeah i mean in fact you know it's almost
too good because um the belt system is
like a multi-tiered
tenure system yeah the point is
your black belt should be temporary as
long as you
stay in
right as long as you demonstrate that
your skill is a match for people at this
level you keep your black belt but it
should degrade you should go back down
that's actually a thing there are some
there are some schools where if you uh
tap out somebody have a higher belt you
swap belts oh that is a good sense to me
yeah yeah so um actually this is kind of
crazy how how well this analogy works
but i'm sure you will not be surprised
to hear
what happened to gracie jiu jitsu well
it exploded in the 1980s with mma it was
like everybody's like oh my gosh this is
obviously closer to truth
we got everybody's got to figure out um
how to use these techniques so it was a
massive vindication for the gracie
family and the gracie school but then
what happened well
they became the experts they became the
guys that had solved there was enough no
more knowledge to learn
in the domain of uh grappling even which
is their domain it's not just martial
arts in grappling in particular they're
like uh you know those leg locks that
some of those uh those people were using
and catch
catch wrestlers over there that's cheap
stuff so like there would be techniques
that they weren't as good at like like
leg locks they would be caught by the
other grapplers and they would then
pooh-pooh those techniques it's the same
story so they became
they're i still have an enormous amount
of respect for them and everything that
they've developed but some of them have
become the experts whose skill level has
not improved since the 1980s they're
still doing the same techniques while
others have continued to evolve and
iterate yeah well have you heard that
story before no i don't know that story
but it does not surprise me i mean no no
i mean in the abstract like is that not
exactly what what happens in that
happens it happens in everything and
it's terrifying right like i fear how do
i i will invest anything in making sure
that doesn't happen to me i think i may
know
now that the solution actually is the
equivalent of students young guns
whatever right you can save this problem
off by making sure that
you are in the arms race that you are
not
resting on
uh on your
your your laurels um
but anyway that is that is fascinating i
did want to say um i hear in the way you
think an awful lot of analogy to the way
i think um
where you're borrowing you know you're a
philosopher right so of course you're
interested in mma right you know
naturally well naturally but i do find
it very natural so the way um
you probably know nothing about my
biology but my specialty is trade-offs
and my claim is that although biological
trade-offs have been long recognized
that we are missing the fact that there
is actually a set of rules that govern
them they are not haphazard things that
emerge here or there that we can
actually specify
um
we can talk about the rules that govern
trade-offs and that
i think essentially every big unanswered
question in biology that i'm aware of
can be readily answered if you approach
it through an understanding of how
trade-offs have to work the fact that
there's a taxonomy of trade-offs
and you know so you may be looking at
different trade-offs but in any case the
point is how did i get there well i did
what you just did with mma i used
some disciplines that i knew well that
were
complex but simpler than biology right
so photography was a very useful one for
me
um aviation yeah yeah yeah yeah bicycles
these were places where there was enough
complexity for there to be trade-offs
but there wasn't so much complexity that
it just got lost in the noise and so if
you can extrapolate from those areas and
then say well all right here's how it
works in a bicycle yes how would that
look in the world of birds you know
it was very clarifying uh yes so
definitely i definitely have similar a
similar story there where um a lot of my
interest not just in academic stuff is
in
let's say extracurricular learning so
i've been fascinated by you know chess
and the jiu jitsu stuff and musical
stuff and i've got a ton of hobbies and
what i found fairly early on is a lot of
the patterns that you discover in chess
are directly applicable to jiu jitsu i
mean they're practically the same thing
if you just orient them a little bit
differently instead of chess pieces
you're dealing with limbs you know and
that this is true of music if you if you
develop
some musical skill you're going to
discover patterns that are generally
applicable
sorry i just needed a notepad here um
yeah it's a it's an issue of variations
on a theme yeah and the the way i you
know this my my note card in my mind for
you know the thing i say to students to
get them to sort of start developing
that understanding is
that the universe
is composed of a very tiny number of
types of objects right just even the
fundamental physics it's not made of
very many things right but it's
obviously hugely variable so if you're
going to build
a universe as complex as this one out of
a tiny number of legos
you're going to get some
themes that repeat right and so being
able to spot them between domains is
effectively it's like a
cheat code it is absolutely and they
build they build on on each other
so you can
you can learn
uh
skills way faster
just by having high skill in a totally
unrelated domain which is also one of
the reasons why i i bulk so hard when
people are skeptical of
interdisciplinary knowledge and claims
like oh no you got to stay in your lane
i'm thinking you got to do the opposite
you got to swerve everywhere you can
like get the biggest truck that's taking
up as many lanes as you possibly can
that's a better way of learning so
here's the reason that they're skeptical
of interdisciplinary studies is because
interdisciplinary studies is a euphemism
for lack of disciplinary studies okay so
they've got the wrong impression but i
agree with you
that i mean in fact this is part of why
um
i love evolutionary biology
since all of biology is evolutionary
this is a license to transgress every
disciplinary boundary you know until you
get to inanimate objects right and so
anyway
yes i agree what what [ __ ] lame you
know
show me the lane marker and i'm going to
cross it it sounds a whole lot like rick
rufus saying oh leg kicks no no no that
doesn't take any skill i don't want to
deal with any of that keep that you keep
the leg kickers in your own game right
well and we saw this in covid and it was
mind-blowing right because it was like
you know
you know
these vaccines couldn't possibly be safe
okay
well but
you're not a vaccinologist
okay but i'm an evolutionary biologist
and the vaccinologists aren't
epidemiologists
and the epidemiologists aren't
virologists and none of them are
evolutionary biologists right and none
of them are physiologists and they
aren't doctors so the point is everybody
is out of whatever discipline they
trained in most of the time in order to
deal with something that has as many
facets as kova did the only people who
had a prayer of doing it well were
either
generalists who were capable of learning
what they needed to know to understand
the other disciplines or clinicians who
were in a position to see what actually
took place with people right so you had
some doctors who didn't have these other
areas of specialty but they could see
the damn pattern
right that worked or being a generalist
who was capable of saying well all right
let me you know here's a new family of
viruses i know nothing about how they
work but i can learn
okay so i don't know if we're ever going
to talk about dark age stuff but i got i
got to go on this line because it's so
interesting i was just having a
conversation about this the other day so
you said the people that are likely to
have
uh the tools to gain high quality models
on covid are going to be people who are
on the ground the practitioners um and
what was the other one
uh
generalists generalists right who can
who can learn on the fly okay
i generally agree agree with you but
that leads to some
i think odd
or unorthodox
conclusions so so here's a question uh
no sorry on the dark horse podcast
unorthodox conclusions are not
acceptable okay
so so
okay
is it so here's a question who has the
final say on the efficacy of drugs oh i
got this one
do the academic researchers or do the
practitioners
um
nature and physiology
okay
right that's it
yeah yeah true okay well look i mean you
know but in terms of who has
not rely more reliable knowledge so if
we have if we have a disagreement as we
did have a disagreement between academic
researchers
doing research and meta research yeah
and practitioners on the ground saying
listen
i'm doing this and here's the results
how do you weigh these practitioners a
hundred percent it has to but that's
that's the same answer i just gave you
incidentally
right i don't care what you think is
true there's a question about what is
actually true
right and so the point is the clinician
and this is why i never understood
what argument was being made with
respect to um
you know
rct's randomized controlled trials and
the efficacy or not of something like
iron right it's like
you have a large number of clinicians
who have been treating with this drug
now it's possible that somebody's no
good at all at what they do and that
they're lying to themselves yes but
you've got a large number of people who
are seeing this pattern in many
different places right people who have
long track records of not losing a
patient since they started with this
protocol right
you can't ignore that if your rct says
this thing doesn't work and your
clinicians are telling you yes but i'm
not losing any patience when i put them
on it now at least you've got a question
how could those two things be
simultaneously true what don't i know
yeah what's testing what is it the case
that that means everybody is fooling
themselves in the field or is it the
case that maybe that's evidence that
something's wrong with the rct
something's wrong with the rct i mean
look i'll even take it one step further
i know it doesn't go this way because we
now know enough about ivermectin and how
it does work and how to apply it
but suppose you just didn't know
anything and suppose what you had was
doctors who use the damn stuff
not losing patience
and then you say well you know
that could be a confound
cool maybe that confound is in their
protocol maybe it's not ivermectin let's
use their protocol
and let's save some lives right and the
point is you're still prioritizing an
rct that doesn't tell you what to do
over people who apparently do know what
to do and actually yes
okay i have an example of this it's
weird
if you'll permit it of course when i was
uh my first research gig i went with bob
trivers to jamaica okay i was studying
lizards in jamaica but it doesn't matter
the local i was way off in the country
right not in kingston i was way off in
the country and there was a bunch of
kids in the neighborhood you know who
you know a bunch of different ages and
they just ran around as a little group
doing stuff all day the way kids might
off in the country and they found me
interesting because i came from
somewhere else and i took them seriously
and i talked to them
anyway that's all unnecessary they did
at some point i had the hiccups and one
of them said that he had a cure for
hiccups and i said oh
and he said yeah do this he said
i want you to spit a big loogie into
your hand and then i want you to take
your finger and put it in there and i
want you to get it on your finger and
paint an x on your forehead
i did it
hiccup's gone
okay
pretty good
next time i had hiccups try it again
works every time
um
now
it's not as crazy as it sounds right
it turns out that the key to it is
getting the loogie in your hand that
creativity that getting that thing to
surface is what does it painting the x
on your forehead is completely pointless
and how would they know right
well i think they did well
i don't know if they knew actually but
that's an interesting question yeah it's
an interesting question probably some of
them do but um
you know probably the joke is that they
can get you to put your own spit on hard
work but but anyway the point is okay
it's a protocol and some of it actually
is useless and some of it is the thing
that works but in a world where you
would throw out a protocol that worked
right because your rct said the drug
wasn't effective like
what kind of fool are you it's pro okay
there's there's so much to say there
okay i do want to give another
interesting example of this
um
so there are a lot of superstitious
beliefs that got a bad rap
from um the scientists of the last
couple of centuries
um
because it turns out that
practices
might work for reasons we don't
understand there's an
yeah right
shocker uh
so one of them i thought i came across
the other day i thought was interesting
was the burning of sage in a graveyard
so if you're trying to approach this in
a non-empirical fashion in academic
fashion you would say they were why what
a ridiculous superstitious practice that
somebody would walk around and burn sage
as a you know as a funeral right there's
it's a non-sequitur you're burning an
herb that is just there's no connection
well it turns out that i guess sage
smoke is some anti antimicrobial
so if you're around corpses
it would actually make sense that that
would be a
practice that is going to
be a good thing to do even if the story
that is told is that it's to ward off
the spirits they people who they might
not know but it still works
so one of the things that dawkins and i
um tangled over
is
so my argument for religion is that it
is literally false but metaphorically
true that's my category literally false
but metaphorically true and what it
means for something to be metaphorically
true
is that
if you act as if it is true
you out-compete someone who acts
according to the fact that it is false
right that's a good way
in other words if you
act so as to go to heaven
you will not find yourself in heaven but
the advantage to your
genes of your having behaved that way
may be so great that it is worth all of
the costs that come along with behaving
that way right so anyway this is this is
exactly and it's like this
let's take take this example
the bible
the old testament
describes yahweh
as being incensed by filth that is [ __ ]
in camp
right yahweh is not cool with people
[ __ ] in camp right okay
well here's the problem yahweh doesn't
actually exist
right so he can't really be incensed
but if you behave as if there's a dude
in the sky who knows everything you do
and he really doesn't like that behavior
it just so happens that you do the same
thing that the germ theory of disease
would lead you to do which is keep feces
away from where people are going to step
in
okay let me let me add a little bit here
so
you've just
given an example i think that
is
what it should sound like when coming
from an evolutionary biologist
that might not be the right way to frame
things though so there's an assumption
when you say that uh you know yahweh
doesn't exist that implies maybe what
richard dawkins conception of yahweh
yahweh is
so so what if it's the case just for
example yeah what if it's the case that
when religious people are talking about
god some of the time not not all
denominations but some of the time
they're actually just talking about
reality or like the structure the
inherent structure of reality now if i
start saying well you're a human and
what is yahweh's relation to humans well
it turns out yahweh really doesn't like
nature reality
structure outside of us doesn't like and
will punish you
for having [ __ ] in the camp now suddenly
that starts to make
a lot of sense i totally i totally
believe this right in fact i talk this
way i deliberately talk this way right
um
because it is important right so my
conception is
religion has various components they do
different jobs okay
the key thing that religion does
is guides you
in ways that affect your behavior so
that your behavior is modified in a way
that enhances your fitness right
there's a lot of story that goes along
with that to make it work to make it
memorable you know to get you to
prioritize things well it story doesn't
have to be true at all in other words
uh atheists focus a lot on the fact that
the creation myths can't possibly be
right
right they're transparently false but
the point is that their purpose is not
to be true right their purpose is to
begin the story to get you in the right
mind frame so that you can get the
advice the advice the directives the
prescriptions are the things that are
where it is capable of affecting your
fitness right so it's like i think of it
as
uh
you know the trunk of a tree the trunk
of a tree is not productive
but the trunk of a tree gets the leaves
up to where they can be productive right
you can't eliminate the trunk because
it's not productive it's a necessary
cost and so anyway i do agree religious
people and i know lots of them and i
talk to them and i have good
relationships with most
they are not
you can't to synonymize them with their
creation myths is absurd yeah it's
pretty posterous it's preposterous um
and that
you know and the other thing well boy
does this one drive uh
people like dawkins nuts
is to point out that the very thing that
religious people do when they
use
vague references to god to sort of fill
in for the part of the story we can't
quite explain in deep
terms is exactly what we do in science
and have to right
good science depends on the ability like
you know okay whatever your discipline
is you're walking into a structure in
which here are some things that we do
understand and then here's some other
things that we do understand and the
things that are between them we don't
yet understand
and we have to put something in that
space that doesn't destroy our ability
to think in the two places that we
understand and it's probably not going
to fit exactly what goes in that space
when we ultimately understand it so the
point is giving yourself leeway to say
something a vague model that is
approximately right that fits in a spot
temporarily is
absolutely necessary yes though
that goes very very very deep
so uh in the story that you have been
telling about what
nature and reality is i think you said
something like you know it's all
reducible to to fundamental bits little
lego pieces is that true the characters
in the novel you're you're telling are
the the fundamental
bits in the in the story that i i would
tell i think one aspect of reality is
the fundamental bits
and very very fundamental i'm a finitist
so i think there's like actually like
lego blocks of space i think that's a
good way of thinking about space but i
also think there is a consciousness that
i cannot find a way to reduce
the texture of my conscious experience
to
three-dimensional spatially extended
lego blocks so i have you're a pan
psychist
not quite i'm actually a method
i'm a pluralist
so i i think that there are
different categories of existence
my guess is there are at least three i
think you have spatially extended blocks
the physical world i think you have
the contents of consciousness which is
something that is not producible to
three-dimensional blocks and then i
think you have an abstract category
which is something like the relation
between the conscious states
and the uh physical states or even the
relations between the physical states
and themselves so if you think about
like the laws of physics for example are
the laws of physics composed of
uh physical building blocks no are the
laws of physics
con
conscious is that is consciousness have
something to do with the laws of figs i
don't think so i think i think they
exist i think the laws of physics exist
i think they do have there's some force
that's gluing states of the universe
together but i would put it in its own
ontological category
so that's that would be pantheism so i'm
i'm a pluralist
i'm sorry what did you say you said uh
pants
pants like a ciao yeah i might be a
pantheist i'm not a panther so i bring
that up
to say
to to
to push you into a corner and say about
your you're telling a story here that uh
where your fundamental concepts might be
incorrect because
is it possible let's say that there
we're entertaining a theory in which
there's physical stuff maybe conscious
states are are in a separate some kind
of a separate system obviously they're
related and then there's an abstract
system maybe that's where the laws of
physics resides or something
um can is there are each of these
equally
fundamental so is it possible that we
could dispense with the abstract stuff
it might be it might be like there's a
theory here i think it's called what's
it called
i forget what it's called but it's
something like you know the laws of
physics are ideas in the mind of god so
maybe all we have is you know physical
stuff and mental stuff
and you know the mental is more
fundamental and you don't need the
abstract stuff
can you dispose with the physical stuff
i actually think you can i think it's
conceivably possible to tell the
idealist story which says that
everything is mental everything is an
experience everything is an idea i don't
take that position but it's at least
conceivably possible that
this the most basic story we tell about
the physical world is wrong
is it possible to dispense with the
existence of consciousness and conscious
mental states i would say no
that one there's there's no
true story that we could tell that is
possibly true
in which
our conclusion is consciousness doesn't
exist so i would actually put the
conscious and the mental at least in
terms of our our uh levels of certainty
i would say it is the existence of mind
that underlies
uh our belief about the mere existence
of the physical world though i do think
there is a physical world
all right
sorry about the monologue no not at all
i appreciate it more than you know
um
so
let me just say a few things and we will
sort them into okay meaning
in the aftermath
one
many of my favorite thinkers
are pan psychists
and i think they are dead wrong about
this and it doesn't matter to me
right it's one of um there's a principle
that a a uh
a contractor i was working with once
said
um that there was often one room in the
house
where all of the
various errors from other parts of the
house had been shunted so there's one
room that just makes no freaking sense
all the angles are wrong yeah you've
pushed every defect you can push it out
of
the rooms but they got to go somewhere
so kind of better to concentrate in that
one closet or whatever
um
and pan psychism strikes me as
where
all of the
error terms
push you
and it causes you to say something i'm
not saying you're a pan cyclist i heard
the distinction that you're drawing but
nonetheless it strikes me that people
who are very clear-headed in realms that
i often care about
um
end up pan-psychist because all of the
error terms get pushed there and it's
like well if we just make consciousness
uh into a fundamental then problem
solved and it's like no
problem deferred not solved right
so here's the other thing
i cannot for the life of me figure out
why
people see consciousness as especially
difficult
okay okay now i'm an evolutionary
biologist and my feeling is yeah
consciousness is difficult in the same
way that a
you know an appendix is is difficult and
uh okay color receptors are but it's
time well i'll take a stab at it let me
let me take a stab at why i think it's
there's a unique problem here good
um so
we can imagine the
the behavior of a brain
being
uh
correlated with conscious experience so
we say okay what is consciousness where
it's something like a brain state is
that what you would say it's like a
processing information processing in the
brain
the definition that heather and i use in
our book
is it is consciousness is that fraction
of cognition that is packaged for
exchange
okay
well let's uh let's strongly overlaps
things that are linguistic
cons so a conscious thought is one that
if somebody said penny for your thoughts
you could convey
okay i think i think that's missing
something so
um i'll try to get at the concept of
pure experience or like the texture of
experience so when you're thinking about
so you can imagine an ape having uh
being exposed to
music
there's sound waves in the air and it
vibrates something in the ear which then
causes some complex electrical
phenomenon up here
you can imagine that happening without
any internal
experience without any subjective
experience yeah right right so so it is
the so the the nature of the subjective
experience i think is in a different
ontological category than the nature of
the physical phenomena
so i agree with this and okay and one of
the things that is very
if you look at a
um
a spider
that is in the process of being
uh attacked by i don't know a bird or
something
it behaves in a way that suggests
panic
yeah
i do not believe there is any reason for
us to imagine
that
there is something in front of us having
the experience of panic
panic is a means to an end
and the end is the same one the spider
is engaged in evasive behavior but i
believe and this is how it is possible
to be wrong about this i'm well aware
that it could be wrong but i don't think
occam's razor being what it is and we
can talk about what is and is not right
about occam's razor but
occam's razor being what it is i don't
think it gives us any extra explanatory
power to imagine that the spider has a
subjective experience
would you say the same about humans
no
it clearly does give us an advantage in
the case of humans and i would argue it
gives a subjective experience
uh
is
strangely distributed across creatures
you will find
substantial subjective experience
in
all
mammals
probably all
birds
um
seems to be in things like cephalopods
octopi for example so so what is it then
that so so we have two theories one is
in which nobody other than bread is
conscious
uh and the other is that the other
things that look like humans are having
a conscious experience
um
what does the theory
add to say
the other creatures are having a
conscious experience but we could we
could explain their behavior just like
we would explain the behavior of the
spider yeah no no
uh you as a philosopher will have to
help me put this into the proper form
okay but
the universe in which i have
consciousness and the other things that
are like me in every regard and
phylogenetically closest to me do not
have it though they behave as if they do
have it is a very strange universe yes
it's strange but it's conceivable right
we can imagine that that's i would not
say it's conceivable i would say it is
possible
somebody could have constructed a
universe in which i was the only
conscious creature and it could look
like this one so that universe is
possible but what would have to be true
for somebody to have constructed a
universe in which i am a constructed
entity with a subjective experience
that's nuts
so so it has to be conceivable in the
sense that that's what we're talking
about that picture so we have a we have
a we're both entertaining the a
different universe in which there is
only one conscious creature yep and and
a lot of other things look very similar
yep the physical structure
i cannot form i mean look it it's uh
it's bertrand russell's teapot orbiting
the sun okay i cannot rule out the
possibility that there's a teapot on the
opposite side of the sun from the earth
right but
i have zero reason to believe that right
so so but the point is not to make an
existence claim to say things are or not
this way the point is to illustrate to
to sharpen the concept of subjective
experience and what it's actually doing
yep so so we have three universes we
have this one and we're not gonna make
any claims about what's going on in this
universe but then we have two other
universes one is which there's only one
conscious entity yep there's only one
subjective
string
experience
and it has to be me and everybody
watching this conversation could say the
same thing right so sure something like
that
um and then the other is where it's uh
it's effectively a um
looks like a duplicate copy of
uh this universe or maybe we could
actually since it's not this universe
let's say there's no consciousness at
all
there's just the behavior there's just
ape-like things all the appearances look
the same yep but there is no
consciousness yep so so i'm saying
if we're evaluating the universe one and
universe two what explanatory power does
it add
to say there is consciousness and
subjective experience taking place in
universe one
when the behavior will be the same in
universe two the
there's just not conscious the internal
experience there yes language is going
to make it difficult to explain
why that's a simple problem
okay the the confines of language but
the basis we can table this by the way
if you wanna this is definitely getting
in the let's uh
in the woods
no no i i'm gonna i'm gonna reducto ad
absurdum okay to to show why this
doesn't work okay
let us agree
that
while
a
whirlwind
going through a junkyard
will never assemble anything
like an airplane
that physically speaking there is
nothing involved in the construction of
an airplane that could not
be accounted for by a randomizing force
acting on physical things sure the
question is
if i now go out and look at airplanes
and i say any airplane that i did not
watch the construction of could be the
result of a random process acting on
parts
and the answer is for some reason
i don't have to
that is not in the realm of the possible
though it's obviously in the realm of
the physically possible
so but but in the in the case of the
consciousness claim i'm not saying i'm
not making an existence claim so so from
my understanding you're saying that the
concept of subjective experience
adds to our explanatory power and maybe
our predictive power and so i'm trying
to make a thought experiment in which
you have the same
external phenomenon the same measurable
phenomenon in some universe it just
doesn't come with the conscious
experience this is sometimes called the
hard problem of consciousness yeah why
should i don't think it's a hard i don't
think it's a hard problem i think it is
i think it is i really don't think it is
and i really don't think it is probably
because from where i sit as an
evolutionary biologist there ain't
nothing hard about this
okay
the fact
when we have to
creatures
that share a trait
there are
two possibilities about why they might
share that trait
they either
inherited it from some ancestor
right so it is identical by descent or
the equivalent
or
it is convergence where they did not get
it from a shared source but the universe
has created it more than once okay so
birds and bats
share wings
because of convergence
birds and birds share wings because of
descent
so the point is you are describing a
universe of creatures that behave as if
they are conscious the way i know myself
to be
and the question is what is the most
likely explanation that something as
complex as subject experience evolved
uniquely in me
yeah without providing an apparent
benefit because everybody else behaves
as if they're conscious
right that's a story i can't make any
sense of chances against it are as
great as the chances against random
forces making an aircraft
okay yeah i think
we might agree with that part probably
not where that goes but with that part
well i think you're making the case here
for free will is what you're saying
that's that's where i would want to take
it to say that the conscious subjective
experience has a causal role yes it has
to it has to
and and believe me i would okay the
argument that i would love so first of
all not i don't want myself strawmanned
on free will okay do i believe that man
has free will
very very little of it
but
much less than we think
but yeah but you're saying but it's got
to be some of it otherwise it wouldn't
be here
right
we can't there's nothing you can do
to i mean first of all if you
if there is no room for free will
in this universe if the universe is for
example fully deterministic
then evolution
doesn't mean what we think it does
there's no such thing as competition
competition is as if competition right
i just love that this has taken a
totally unexpected turn so the the
disagreement
stems maybe from uh uh
differences and perspectives of free
will so you're a free will guy it's so
interesting i'm not a freewill guy no it
sounds like you're a free will no no
you're a little free will guy yeah yeah
when it comes to free will my answer is
not zero
brett you're not gonna believe this so i
disagree with your uh uh uh ontology
here and i think there is a hard problem
of consciousness i'm a substance
pluralist where i think you have two-way
interaction between mind and body and
body and mind but they are they are
uniquely different and there's a
shocking uh
there's a shocking fact that there
should be consciousness when contrasted
with the rest of the physical universe
like the difference between a unit of
three-dimensional space and the feeling
of hearing music is just staggering to
me but i also agree with you i think we
do have there's a room for a little bit
of free will you do it's it's sort of i
do
it it's it's not a lot yeah it's
something like this you have free will
to the
to the extent that the universe has put
you in an environment such that you can
exercise it which may not which may only
happen farther down the evolutionary
process right and then i will go one
step further and i will say
that that that
there is and this is a an um
this is a value judgment this is
normative but
given that there is not zero free will
that there is actually
certainly value
and maybe a moral obligation to attempt
to enlarge the amount of free will
available not just to you but to your
descendants and to your fellow humans
it's possible i
based on everything else that you have
said
i'm going to i'm going to plant my flag
i'm going to say
if you
walk down that road you're going to end
up in a place that does not look like
an atheist
evolutionary biologist
perspective because i'm not an atheist
oh i assume that you were i thought i
heard that somewhere well people say it
of me and my feeling is that any
religious person who hears me describe
what i believe will call me an atheist
but
i can't really be one because
if i believe
that
belief a if i believe that
scientists in order to do their work
properly have to have
beliefs that are
de facto
faith-based just to even get the work
done
and i believe that people whose
orientation is religious
are
engaged in utilizing the exact same
structure
in order to navigate life
then the distinction
is
quite artificial and i think frankly
it's classist at some level right i feel
like this is just going to open up this
an infinite can of worms here because i
i i appreciate that perspective but i
have not encountered the argument that
says we have to have the faith
oh i come yeah yeah
we'll talk about there's something else
i really want to talk about but let's
have that conversation because you seem
shocked by it so that's got to be yeah i
mean it seems to me we can dispense with
this one really easily okay okay good so
first of all descartes cheated right i
think therefore i am is a cruddy proof
that doesn't prove anything okay okay
but it is a necessary proof and the
reason it isn't necessary proof is
because if you cannot establish that you
exist
right
then
anything that you wish to do if you
believe that you need to start with the
basics and work your way up yeah
if you there's no way to prove that you
do exist if descartes proof which sucks
i disagree does it well it depends on on
the formulation of descartes proof so
how about this one let me let me throw
one out there
and and see if this is uh falsifiable
okay it is the case that there is at
least one conscious state taking place
in the universe at this moment
um
i mean it strikes me
yeah i mean it is it's the cart in a
without the person aspect because
sometimes people object to descartes and
they say well what is a person and i'm
just saying
no no no outside i like it it's like the
i'm trying to remember whether the uh i
guess the mott is the more robust
version yeah yeah we're just persons
aside they're consciousness
yeah conscious and consciousness
something
that's a proof i would almost accept
there are mental states yeah we could
yeah
there's something that seems like a
solid foundation though i have a hard
time thinking
here's the reason that you need
descartes version and that that more
robust version doesn't get you where you
need to go okay
because if i'm to do
science
i need to exist
but you don't need but you don't need a
proof that you exist
this is the point yeah i absolutely do
not need a proof that i exist
right what we can do is we can say let's
just cheat
assuming i exist i see everything i'm
going to conclude for the rest of my
life if i don't turn out to exist then
all that stuff is garbage i see i see
okay so let me let me try to articulate
this principle and see if you uh agree
with it or not okay
there are some
objective discoverable even certain
truths
but they don't get you very far
truths like
consciousness is taking place
truths like there i think there are
other logical truths if there are
objects in the world than they are
however they are and they aren't however
they aren't it doesn't tell you much
about the world but i think there's a
there's a there's an aspect of logical
necessity and if you want to do science
there are all kinds of
reasonable assumptions that you have to
make that you might be wrong but you
have no reason to believe that you're
incorrect all right okay i think what
we're looking for here and i think we're
circling around the same concept and
we're because we don't share a language
yet it's a little hard to wrestle it to
uh
into a statement
my feeling is
let's take the big bang
yeah and i'm gonna make a confession
i am a believer in the big bang
though i can't even imagine
what i could possibly take to be useful
evidence that such a thing existed i
know it's a story that people
like i know that its effect on
my work is zero
i don't need the universe to have
started with a big bang to for there to
be an earth with living creatures on it
for me to understand how they work
so it's not really important whether
i've got it right or not and if i found
out tomorrow that the big bang was the
wrong story and it was some other story
they'd be fine right but the basic point
is look the story of science
starts with the big bang
okay it starts with the big bang and
from there you know you get the plasma
and it cools and you get the creation of
you know hydrogen and then you get some
supernovas and they create heavier
elements and blah blah blah blah blah we
can do that thing but the basic point is
look i need something at the beginning
of the story so i can get to the part i
give a [ __ ] about right yeah okay
now my point is my own
you know descartes and his establishing
that he must exist or he couldn't be
thinking
right that's good enough
to get you to i am capable of observing
the universe and therefore conducting
science within it and if that turns out
that i don't exist then or it turns out
the universe doesn't exist and it's an
illusion then the science i do in it
won't be right but it's not going to
hurt anybody you know
um and so the basic point is look hey
that's good enough i need to cheat proof
at the beginning i need the universe to
exist big bang i need myself to exist
descartes and now i'm going to go do
some work and if it turns out that those
things are really way off what have i
lost
okay so our disagreement then might be
around
this idea of faith because i think you
can build up a reasonable story about
what you are about the big bang about
you as a scientist i don't i wouldn't
consider those are aspects of faith i
mean unless you mean i don't have a like
a logical proof because i grew up around
a lot of faith and that my i grew up
evangelical christian community there
was a lot of faith which was not
synonymous with a lack of proof okay
okay now i think i got you right where i
want you okay
um because what you said earlier in the
comments
okay was that you thought that religious
people when they were speaking about you
know
god yahweh and his feelings about filth
really weren't speaking about like a guy
and feelings that right was sort of a
placeholder for you know
no filth in camp you know because it's
bad the universe doesn't like that [ __ ]
right yeah um so i agree with that and
my point is look
if that's faith if faith is okay we're
going to talk about yahweh and he's like
a guy and he has feelings about the
universe we should take them seriously
even though he's not really a guy and he
doesn't have feelings right if that's
what faith really is okay then the point
is that's the faith i have to go do my
science i have faith that the universe
exists that it probably came from
something big bangish and that i exist
enough that i can uh perceive the
universe and uh make useful conclusions
about it
that's my faith but the point is it is
it is hypocritical of me
to avail myself of that tool to do my
work and then be critical of people who
believe it about yahweh okay so so i
i think we have to sharpen the
distinction of religious people here so
when i say
um maybe this is what religious people
are saying as they're using different
language to talk about the universe that
is
not
uh correct because if you talk to
religious people they will absolutely
insist some of them some percentage of
them will say i am not speaking
metaphorically i am speaking literally
so so i think actually this this could
tie back into um
uh academia a bit and the dark age the
dark age idea and how we make sense of
things over the 20th century where
there's some there's something i don't
have a word for yet
which is somebody presents you with a
set of ideas
and they say these are really good ideas
but they're really good ones are the
person-ness of god and the the
personality of yahweh and they pick on
they say this is this is the thing that
i believe
there's the thing that happens which you
you can look at the package that they
presented with you say wow this is a
beautiful package and there is so much
truth to be found here and yet the
things that you have pointed out
as being the important truths
are false and your your theory
that you've got some underlying truth
packaged together and then you've got
like the bow on top and you think that
the what you're presenting is this
beautiful bow and you're like really
really obsessed with the quality of the
bow and how nice it is i'm like okay i
don't like the bow but there there is
truth to be found there and that this is
what happens in religion i think all the
time because i grew up around it there's
a whole bunch of people making very
insistent claims about history and
they're kind of right
but if you tell them why they're right
they'll disagree with you and they'll
say no no that's you know you're a
heretic something okay but do you
remember your point about the sage in
the in the cemetery yeah
okay so some of
what religion contains
is uh virus protection
right because religion carries all of
this power the danger of it being
captured by something that is either
foolish or uh nefarious is very great
yeah so it has to have mechanisms built
into it to fend off things that would
capture that voice i mean
uh taking the lord's name in vain
doesn't mean cursing it means speaking
with the authority of the lord when you
ain't the lord right
why is that bad because you can take you
can get people to stop behaving in their
own interests and start behaving in your
interest if you can get them to do that
so they have to be resistant to anybody
who would try
so anyway my point would be
the no i'm really talking literally and
i'm really talking about a guy
right
um
that's a troubling claim to me as it
sounds like it is to you
on the other hand you can imagine that
if the point is as soon as you get
kind of philosophical about this and you
say well
you know it's not really
supernatural right once you start
playing around with it's not really
supernatural and it's not really a guy
and you're not going to a lake of fire
and all that stuff and the point is the
safety is off the gun
right and what happened for some for
some
well no maybe for all of us
so i would point out
that um
civilization
has lost its goddamn mind obviously
right and is putting us in
tremendous unnecessary danger
right we're taking the most beautiful
gift that we could possibly imagine
right not only are we possessed
of consciousness with which to
appreciate this beautiful universe but
we have also been handed the tools
to
make our make of our time what we will
rather than be obligated to
uh feed ourselves by
you know tilling the earth or hunting
the creatures we have the opportunity to
use our consciousness for amazing things
not for just getting by and we would
blow that we would blow that over this
insanity over whatever the competition
whether it's you know
covid madness or nuclear games or you
know uh combo struggle over oil
the idea that's so foolish that we would
do that
that um what i would say is
what are the chances that our insanity
our squandering of the amazing
opportunity that we've been handed is
actually the result of the fact that we
realized you could dispense with an
awful lot of
the wisdom that was handed to us and
nothing bad happens the bridges don't
fall down
right yeah no god does not flood the
earth
right so i wonder
i wonder how safe this is and whether or
not our despair you know the people who
are focused on the bow
are actually also involved in something
mind you i'm not arguing we should go
back to those beliefs i don't i think
they're antiquated they don't work
right they're out of phase with our
modern problems but i do think the
reason that people are so reluctant to
give them up may be okay they're they're
adhering to a belief structure that got
us this far and their point is if you
abandon that belief structure everything
fails and well
yes and i think recent events have
played that out so so again having grown
up in the the christian evangelical
community
there was a lot of uh
hostility towards
careful skepticism i guess i guess you
could say and
the argument was essentially a moral one
that you know you let the devil in the
door and then he's gonna you know let
his foot in the door and he's gonna
knock down the house and then suddenly
you've you know you've lost your faith
and and
there was lots of um arguments
appeals to the slippery slope they said
oh well you can't socially allow x
because then it's going to allow y which
is going to allow z and they were right
about a ton of those things i remember
i remember you know the intellectual
community
back in the day would mock the
unsophisticated evangelicals for
their arguments um and you know where
where things are going to go and why
they're going that direction and i think
history has demonstrated that in a lot
of respects they're right now i'm not
sure so but i'm not sure is
whether historical peoples
believed the the interpretations that we
ascribe to them like people like um
lawrence krauss um when they're talking
or or christopher hitchens you know the
there is a story that is told about the
unsophistication of religious thought
when taken literally as if that's
representative of historical religious
thought and i'm just not sure it is oh i
agree
yeah
i guess my point would be
you know there's this place where
um
i moderated the debate between sam
harris and jordan peterson
and they hang up on this question where
um
you know
harris is pushing peterson this is my
recollection i hope i have it right but
harrison is is pushing peterson about
whether he really believes
in you know
jesus's divine
being
something like that do you really
believe
and peterson says
i act as if i do
and harris
has this reaction like he's just one
like peterson has just admitted
something embarrassing or said something
that makes no sense and the crazy thing
is i hear peterson say that
and i say
you just answered the question perfectly
yeah that's that's almost a much
stronger answer than to say i believe it
than to say i am acting on it right and
the irony of course is
to say i act as if i do is like one
admission i'm gonna step out of
character
for 15 seconds and i'm going to tell you
what's really going on here i act as if
i do now i'm going back into character
right and the point is i only came out
of character because you're being a dick
about it because you're pushing me
you're saying do you really believe do
you really believe and the point is if i
really believed i wouldn't say i don't
really believe
but my
the point is the behavior
and so anyway
the interchange is interesting because
i heard it as if he just spoke
literal truth about his own internal
state conveyed it ended the argument and
harris heard it as if harris had just
caused an embarrassing revelation
which was strange
yeah i uh while i'm confused about the
word act now because maybe maybe harris
was interpreting that as saying i am i
am participating i'm knowingly
participating in theater i'm pretending
as if i do versus i am acting on the
belief like i i act which means i
believe it at a much deeper level well
what i heard him say was effectively
i don't worry too much about
whether i believe or don't quite believe
the point is i act as if i do and this
doesn't preoccupy me
once you're going to be acting as if you
believe
then you know you you don't want to get
caught in some infinite loop of what
does it really mean that i believe right
the point is you've done the important
part you've decided how am i going to
make decisions that are tough calls i'm
going to think about what i would do
in light of this set of beliefs
and go forward
and
you know if you believe as i do that
those belief systems are
adaptive that they are products of
evolution
i i
mind you i think peterson is making a
kind of an error and the error is that
those belief systems are adaptive but
they are not adapted to our modern
environment
so there's a danger
behaving as if god exists
made a great deal of sense and it makes
less sense every hour
because those beliefs are adapted to a
past environment i just think that that
concept of god is so complex and it
means such radically different things to
so many people i i don't i don't even
think
i don't know how responsible it is to to
say either way believing in god not
believing in god because if you if you
take a poll
of people who would agree with the
sentence i believe in god and then you
were to scratch the surface and say what
do you mean by that you're going to get
wildly different answers oh i agree and
i think actually this
is a tough problem
right it's it's exactly analogous to uh
you as a philosopher will know what this
is called but the idea that i cannot in
any way establish that what i experience
when i look at something blue isn't what
you experience when you look at
something yellow and
now i can make a strong argument about
why that's unlikely to be true but i
can't prove it
um and this what you know what does
somebody really mean when they say they
believe is one of these and the basic
point is it doesn't really matter as
long as a congregation of people that's
interacting
uh
comes out to the same conclusions about
what that belief should imply about
behavior
okay so this has been a wonderful aside
or i don't know maybe this is the main
main
thread on religion i really would love
to talk about uh go back to something
we were talking about a long while ago
and um i think i have an important
concept that i would love to run by you
good
okay
so i'm trying to think how to bring it
bring it back
together okay
if it's the case that we find ourselves
in a circumstance
in which people who are supposed to be
high quality thinkers are not doing a
very good job
and we're pointing out maybe there are
big errors over here big errors over
there we haven't gone into the history
maybe we can do that at some other point
it's a very rich history here of
spectacular errors being made and held
onto for long periods of time and then
only you know science only progressing
as they say uh coffin by coffin funeral
by funeral yeah yeah something like that
so okay
here's a claim there are discoverable
patterns of
error that are
apparent across disciplines and they
have something in common there's a
particular way of thinking that i'm
starting to see crop up
across disciplines
that is so universal it makes me think
something like we're in a dark age and i
would describe it as um
the simple way is saying is uh
underestimating the complexity of the
world
but there's something more technical
going on here which is the process of
information loss
when people are thinking about
uh complex phenomena let me give you a
example that is recently researching and
i think you'll find this interesting
okay this is so funny right so um
in 19
in the mid 1980s
there was this paper that was published
i forget by
i forget who the author was and it was
supposed to demonstrate that the um the
supposed hot hand in sports was a
fallacy there was a mistake it was
actually it's widespread uh cognitive
misfiring there is no such thing as the
hot hand or getting in the zone this
even made it into daniel kahneman's book
thinking fast and slow this was like you
know wow a triumph of statistics and
math and analysis over what uh these
unsophisticated practitioners believe
which is that you can get in the zone
and there is such a thing as a hot hand
so so for multiple decades
the there was the hot hand fallacy was
held up as an example of the superiority
of let's call it uh
mathematical
uh data analysis over other techniques
okay
turns out that that
uh idea that there is a there is a hot
hand fallacy fallacy
which is thinking that by looking at the
data and the way that they looked at the
data they could arrive at a conclusion
that turns out to be incorrect for a few
reasons i'll give you some
a couple of simple examples so
the way that they try to conclude that
there is no such thing as the hot hand
is by looking at
streaks of performance in um player
performance i think it was the person
analyzed like one year of the boston
celtics and basketball and was trying to
say you know do we see evidence that
there are streaks or is it fairly random
and there is there is no streaking
taking place so they did the analysis
and they said oh well we looked at the
data which is of course the important
thing to do you look at the data and you
draw the conclusion i see no evidence of
streaks therefore it's a widespread
cognitive
illusion
well
okay
it turns out they didn't take into
account
that
defenses in basketball will adjust their
behavior based on the performance of the
person who's streaking
so if you look at the data and you don't
see a change you see the same pattern
despite the defense changing it's
you know it's double teaming somebody
that it wouldn't otherwise do that means
the person is streaking you're looking
at the same data but you're going oh no
that's actually evidence that there is a
stream there are other mistakes that are
made uh this is just in the past like 10
years there's a bunch of research coming
out saying oh by the way
hot the hot hand is a thing all of those
unsophisticated sports people like
everybody in the domain of sports who
has done anything physical will
understand that getting in the zone is a
thing like all of sports psychology is
about getting in the zone and yet here
you have these academics going
you don't understand
you haven't you don't understand the
sophisticated mathematics involved okay
so anyways i bring that up turns out
there they were wrong this is a gigantic
embarrassment people should be
embarrassed it looks like they might
have even made statistical errors
themselves not only was their data uh
mistaken but they might have they might
have essentially made uh uh a mistake
a a justifiable mistake because of
something called the monty hall paradox
i don't know if you're familiar of
course it's like a it's a very
extremely unintuitive result in uh
statistics it's anti-intuitive it's it's
anti-intuitive though there are pretty
good examples once you get the concept
make sense of what's going on but when
you the first time you encounter it
you're gonna go this is obviously
something is broken here anyway it looks
like they sort of might have made a
similar error
uh a subtle error in
the the paper that was published in 85
anyway so their their data is bad
quality they didn't take into account um
uh how defenses adjust they might have
made statistical errors and they didn't
account for like shot placement where
you were on the court
you know if you're if you've got a
streak and you're like making layups
versus you're an inch inside the
three-point line you're going to throw
the lump those into the same thing and
then draw
like that's silly okay so anyway i bring
that up to say
this this is
the essence of the pattern that keeps
happening over and over and over it is
people
trying to do math
in systems that are so complex they do
not lend themselves to the doing of math
why because there is information loss
there are critical variables that people
are not taking into account when they
try to do the math they try to look at
the data they think the data speaks for
itself it does not if you're not taking
into account shot placement defensive
strategy whether or not the offensive
psychology has changed like there's a
whole basket of complex things here that
you're not taking into account so the
result is information loss so actually
on this note apparently some of this new
um
evidence that's coming out on hot hand
research is showing in a bunch of
different domains of course the hot hand
is a thing like no shocker there didn't
take 30 years of academic theorizing to
figure that out
one of the ways one of the approaches to
discovering this is by more advanced
statistics where they take into account
things like shot placement and when you
you take that variable and take out you
go
okay well i guess um my conclusions
didn't follow for my simplistic
assumptions it is that pattern brett
that pattern of information loss from
from abstraction errors that is
absolutely everywhere it's in math
itself
it's in physics it comes up in uh
coveted
related situations if i were to say to
you brat
don't you know there is a
graph an exponential chart of coveted
infections that that means x y and z and
didn't you see the mathematical model
that the guy in oxford came up with it's
all the same type of error simplistic
model of reality because
you are you're
you're have less information
that you're putting into your models
than is out there in the world
yeah
so many different places we could go
from here but yes i totally resonate
with this interpretation and i think
there's
as you may well think there's more to it
i mean for one thing the economic
incentives
actually foster people not to discover
this error because it basically creates
a landscape of work to be done that can
be remunerated
but
if this thing is set in motion and in
fact in your dark uh dark age piece
you say something it's very close to
something that i often say
you talk about the
the
tendency to oversimplify
and what i would argue is that we
part of what is going wrong and why we
are so stuck
is
we made our early gains scientifically
in the simple fields
and that creates a problem because what
it does is it causes you to think the
rules of science are the rules of
science that work for simple fields and
and what simple fields are you talking
about chemistry and physics
right which is unintuitive if people
don't like usually i think people think
physics is the most complex it's not
it's maybe so maybe the hardest
cognitively but it's the simplest stuff
it's just very foreign from our
experience control for the most
variables right
so we made our early gains there and
then we went oh now we know how to do
science and when you apply those rules
to biology for example it's a no-go
because the complexity makes those rules
laughable right yeah and we are not good
at correcting for it so we haven't
updated science
um
the other thing is something i haven't
heard you mention
which is that and again at the level of
the interface between
our scientific practice and the
incentives surrounding it
we make this mistake which i swear
causes any field to bog down
and the mistake it first of all i would
argue
that diminishing returns
um important concepts often get
mislabeled because they get very closely
associated with
the first place that they were spotted
so i would argue diminishing marginal
returns is one of the most important com
complex systems concepts
in the universe
and that it's overly associated with
economics which is the first place it
was seen ironically because economics is
simple enough to see it right
the point is diminishing returns ought
to afflict any system that has two
characteristics
complexity
and an objective
so there's no diminishing returns in a
hurricane there's complexity
but there's no objective right but if
you've got an objective against which to
define something like a return
and complexity you'll see diminishing
returns
so here's my point
let's say you've got a field field x
somebody comes up with an insight in
field x that's really important right
the next important thing has been
discovered a flurry of work happens
that's all very productive okay this
causes
the field to decide that that insight
is
fundamental
and to award the school of thought that
owns that insight
all of the resources because the return
on investment is so big right who else
would you give them to these are the
people who have the hot hands right
okay now you've given all of the
resources to the school of thought that
had this insight
that insight is going to peter out it's
going to hit diminishing returns that
school of thought is now the only game
in town every other school of thought
dies off nobody remembers how to do it
and eventually the school of thought
hits a plateau
and the point is we're just going to
keep doubling down because we know we're
right because look how productive we've
been right and the point is no you
should never have edited down to one
school of thought
right at the very least yes you would be
slower when the flurry of progress is
happening you'd be slower if you had at
least two schools of thought live
but at the point that your school of
thought peters out you need the next
most promising school of thought to tell
you what to do next and we never do this
so every field is almost always stuck
right there's an immediate analogy here
to the process of
thinking critically
if you have not arrived at the truth and
you have
plausible theory a
that is totally uh incommensurate with
plausible theory b
just because you're preferring a now
doesn't mean you throw b away or c or d
you go okay well maybe there are many
different maybe there are concepts in
the different theories that are going to
piece together the thing i'm missing in
the dominant theory and that's sort of
the same thing that you're describing
here just at like an institutional level
at an individual level yes exactly and i
would argue one of uh
i hope this doesn't sound like bragging
but one of the things that i think i do
lots of stuff badly but one of the
things i think i do best you're an ape
brad don't worry
i am extremely
patient
if i don't know the answer to a question
right i can take a question and i can
file it in an incomplete state and i can
wait a decade
yeah and you have to be able to do that
because if you feel pressure and you
take the closest thing you've got to an
answer and you force it to be an answer
then
you end up
a missing the answer when it when you
finally have enough pieces of the puzzle
to get it right
you don't even know you're still asking
right you think you knew the answer and
so you reject the real answer and
so anyway it's like two schools of
thought in your mind and i literally
believe that being of two minds
is downstream that consciousness evolved
to allow two people
to
pool cognitive resources but that as a
secondary effect the ability for one
person to do it with themself
uh
is
is a secondary adaptation
so
yeah i really like that idea and um
if you pursue that approach not just
with two ideas but with you know you
have five different theoretical
explanations for something and then one
of the one of them is like
uh
a basket for all the other possible
theoretical
things that you're not thinking of right
now but maybe you could approach it
differently that pays returns because
i've experienced i've done this the
wrong way
several times whereas like oh i just
really
assumed that x was true and was building
building building and then my
cavalierness bit me in the butt later
where i go okay actually that that
little one critical assumption i thought
was reasonable turned out to be wrong
and i sort of got to start from scratch
but i've also experienced that in return
where i go you know if i'm being honest
i'm like 90 confident about this aspect
of a theory i don't know but i'm just
going to keep the door open a little bit
maybe you could have a wild alternative
theory and then time passes and time
passes you go oh you know i'm glad i
kept the door open here because i
already have models built alternative
models built out where necessary
totally totally and it becomes uh
it becomes an art you know where you
know there's a there's a bayesian aspect
of this where you know yes i think this
is probably the right explanation here
there's something about it that's
bugging me
um and i'm going to proceed as if it's
true but i'm going to keep track of
what's stacked on top of it so if it
turns out it isn't true i immediately
know what else i believe that i need to
go back and check exactly now the
consequences of that the consequences of
that though are you have to seriously
entertain wildly different schools of
thought about any given uh
idea which people do not seem
uh comfortable with at all
if you're gonna say okay i recognize you
know i'm making my jinga tower and this
one
this one i might not be able to build on
there can be a whole lot of jenga blocks
a whole lot of people decades of theory
and money and prestige on the line
and that one might be wrong and you pull
it out and you go okay look i've already
i've already got a separate system i'm
not going to be devastated but
that
there are big stakes involved if you
keep track of what follows from what
right and the world is not set up for
this right you know you have stacked a
discipline on top of a risky assumption
and then that assumption comes up bad
the institution the uh
the
the subject the all of the people
involved will rationalize pretending
that the thing that they now know isn't
true is true in order just to keep the
the artifice running
yes and and sometimes in in in shocking
ways so this happens in uh medical
science uh which you know there are a
lot of bad domains of scientific inquiry
but if i had to say on net what has the
most immediate negative impact on
people's lives i think it's medicine i
think modern medicine has all kinds of
terrible ideas that are damaging people
it's like
yeah it's a killer
for real um but there's to describe this
process of rationalization
i have heard people say effectively we
have to speak about our errors in
paraphrasing you have to speak about our
errors in a muted voice otherwise
the masses will lose faith
in us
the credibility of science is on the
line
right and say that as if they're you
know they're the the keepers of
of the truth
well and like the people you know i can
understand the reasoning i just think
it's it's really bad i think it's a
really really bad idea all right so um
we are incidentally talking around and
around and around
the dark age um and
we will get there now or next time but
um but the uh
here's what here's the problem
or one of the fundamental problems
think about for the moment just think
about cultural evolution as an analog to
genetic evolution take dawkins modern
view just say it's an analog okay okay
well there's an analog then to
um
mutation rate
yeah
culture
is very creative and experimental
compared to genes
right
but that means it is producing new
variants at a furious pace
but they go extinct really quick because
they're almost all wrong right
now here's the problem
the glory of science the beauty of it
the power of science comes from the fact
that given enough runway
it is a self-correcting process that
gives us insight yeah the day-to-day
back and forth in any given department
or field or journal or whatever
is near noise
and the problem is because these two
things go by the same name
science is
that which we have learned through this
process and science is also the furious
buzzing process that produces that
knowledge because we think of those as
the same thing
we have this urge to take whatever just
came out of the lab
and put it in the new york times and
tell you how to change your diet and the
point is
you just came up with that you don't
know if it's true i get that you have an
experiment that says it's true
and five years ago there was the
experiment in the new york times saying
the exact opposite right yeah and so the
point is science if you take the latest
the latest science is nuts the science
that has stood the test of time is
science you might want to put your
weight on but the last thing you want is
your doctor or your nutritionist
up on the latest
insights and applying them to you you'll
get mauled you'll get maimed you know
it's a terrible idea i i completely
agree uh there i don't know if this is a
good idea or a bad idea but there are
enormous connections between what you've
just said and
how markets function
so there's a lot of criticism that
people throw at markets where they're
looking at the short term and they're
saying ah but look the market produced
dangerous good x therefore we need some
type of state intervention to correct
this process and then uh
market adherence will say no no but in
the long run when you zoom out in the
big picture it is a self-corrective
mechanism which i actually believe to be
true often i think the the the
pessimistic conclusion is the most
accurate one that yeah science might be
a self-correcting process but if you're
talking in 150 year cycles right and
yeah i do think uh
uh the profit and loss incentive in a
market is sufficient to punish bad
behavior such that
in the long run
uh uh
bad products will be out competed by
good ones but in the short run that
might be
decades of some dangerous thing being
sold on the market
that has unintended consequences we
didn't understand
and i don't think that there is a
good resolution to that i think we sort
of from what i can tell i don't think i
i think the approach that
we're going to have a state come in and
regulate the companies to prevent the
dangerous products from being sold is
sort of like having this a state of
academics composed of academics come in
and say no no we have to now set the
record straight of the ideas uh and
we're not going to let the
self-corrective process happen i think
there's a lot of similar similarities
here totally and you can see the
disaster with covet
right
so
okay
they took a virus
and they enhanced it for human
infectivity for whatever garbage reason
they came up with
that couldn't possibly be a good idea
right
[Laughter]
it's nothing that could be true that
would have made that a good gamble but
they did it and it got out
and it made lots of people sick and
killed lots and lots of people and i
believe the full toll of that virus is
far from understood
but then
we got it
we've got this brand new vaccine
it's based on an entirely new technology
and this cartoon that describes how it
works says exactly why it's going to
make you safe and you're going to get to
go back to life
i looked at that heather and i looked at
the description of this i agree it is a
technologically marvelous
new
mechanism for
informing the immune system
it's so far from ready to inject into a
human being
or a billion
well that's just the thing
i wouldn't inject it into one human
being
given how many unknowns as you say the
um
the degree to which they lost sight that
they did not recognize the complexity or
didn't care oh man of what they were the
intervention they were proposing and how
radically different this was from
anything that they had done successfully
before
right
that was just
a shocker and then
the idea that they wanted to vaccinate
everybody was like
first we vaccinate the world could you
come up with a worse concept in
biology than that
let's take a novel vaccine that that
affects the most complex system in the
known universe which is the human body
in ways we don't understand and give it
to try to give it to everybody
let's put it this way
i mean a you knew they were insane
when
they started with the idea that they
were going to vaccinate all the
frontline workers
yeah
but
how about a half
how about we just
start with half right you just you don't
want to take all of anything and gamble
it on this experiment
right this is this is
these are these are people so
remote from the level of complexity they
are intervening with um that they just
they couldn't
i'm struggling to find words to explain
how irresponsible this was even if there
was no evidence in the trials that there
was anything to worry about
right right this level of novelty
with all of humanity i'm sorry that is
just
it's crazy it's unimaginably dangerous
we're kind of in an interesting zone
here that i can't think of any other
comparable time that i've experienced
and probably
nobody has experienced in this lifetime
which is
if if you're correct and i would say in
this case if i'm correct that the
cost benefit um was extremely bad it was
outrageously risky
then in the long run i think more time
is going to reveal this and and you know
consequences from intervention
intervening to the immune system might
not be known for two decades oh yeah
three decades like
so it's an interesting position to be in
though because
it's almost like
if you want to put your
theory to the test this is a great time
to do it because how many times could
you say with confidence
i think there was a a
error
a historic error has been made here
that we have not seen the full
consequences
thereof that doesn't happen very much so
it's kind of it's in a weird in an
intellectual sense it's kind of an
interesting opportunity like i happen to
think intervening in complex systems
is probably not a good idea that's true
economically biologically politically
you know culturally
and in this case because it was such a
spectacular intervention like
unprecedented intervention my guess
would be we're going to have an
unprecedented
disaster unfold because of it over the
next few decades
yeah
and i'm open to being wrong it'll be
interesting to see if that plays out
that's true
it does not have to be the case that a
disaster is revealed in order for it to
have been unconscionable
sure sure it could have been russian
roulette and
well there's two claims the one claim is
it was a like a immoral decision and
foolish and the other claim is like a
causal claim that the output is actually
going to be
very bad well i think we already i mean
it's interesting to me that you're
cautious about saying i think we already
see
you know especially with the mrna
uh transfection agents
we already see
an impact on all-cause mortality that
causes the return to be negative and
that's only a couple that's a year and a
half out from the beginning well so so
the reason i'm being cautious is because
the uh if you're if you're trying to
look at the scope of possible disaster
yep to have a a increase all-cause
mortality bump will make the history
books but it's not like it's not like oh
my gosh this is black plague yep
this goes all the way to
genuinely unprecedented disaster for
humanity i'm not saying that's what's
going to happen i don't know but that's
definitely on the table it's all on the
table it's all on the table but i just
want to point out
if they had gambled recklessly yeah
um
and gotten lucky
that would not be a vindication
of their
uh mechanism of decision making yeah
right
and i mean you know in fact we're stuck
in this position with respect to covet
itself
right we are now battling
we had won the battle over lab leak and
now there's this full court press to
reverse the story and say oh actually it
really did come from the the seafood
market right it's nonsense evidentiary
the the evidence is not there to suggest
a reversal of this conclusion at all but
what people don't realize is that we are
having a proxy battle over whether the
right thing to do
is to stop gain of function research or
quadruple it
yeah right because if it did come out of
the wet market
then the laboratory across the river
wasn't fast enough it didn't have enough
money it should have studied harder
because maybe we could have prevented it
right and if it did come out of the
laboratory then the point is well the
wet market wasn't the concern
it was the goddamn laboratory you did
this it's a self-inflicted wound it's
literally the same process of keynesian
reasoning and economics the idea that we
need the government needs to intervene
to to stimulate the economy and then
when the stimulation doesn't work they
say well we didn't stimulate enough in
fact thank goodness we stimulated it
because it would have been worse if we
didn't stimulate so next time we need a
quadruple dose to really get the economy
going it's the same same reasoning it's
fizer logic before pfizer
[Laughter]
um
yeah well oh man um how much time do you
have
i have about 20 20 minutes or so okay um
shall we switch into instead of talking
around the uh the dark age question
shall we at least open that
sure uh yeah the thing that i am unsure
about is uh to to gauge the depth versus
breadth because there's a lot of
both here that's really interesting so
yeah i don't stop me if i'm going down
uh rabbit holes um if you want to talk
specifics oh the rabbits will stop you
okay yeah they don't take kindly to
people coming down their holes i don't
know that but
no go ahead oh uh oh or do you want me
to uh oh yeah i thought it was gonna be
a prompt of some sort yeah yeah a prompt
um well okay so
as as we discussed at the top of the
podcast you have argued so i have long
believed that we were in a dark age
i were in a a cryptic dark age that one
was dawning
i have my own set of terminology
surrounding this uh
i call i i would argue that every dark
age has people who continue
to
do science that they can be very obscure
oftentimes their entire product is
probably lost to history
i call these keepers of the flame
and so there's that
but in any case the degree to which
science has been unhooked by
market forces and replaced by things
that you know basically cargo cult
science to use feynman's terminology for
it is extreme it has grown even much
more extreme than when i started
thinking about this but when i ran into
your work and i found that a i'm not the
only person on earth who thinks that
dark age is not too strong a term but b
what really surprised me about your your
work
was how long into the past
you believe that process has been going
on you you put the start date of our
dark age
way earlier than i would have even
thought
to place it and so let's talk a little
bit about why you think we're in a dark
age and why you when you think it
started
what changed and uh
you know why so early
the the first part of the question the
reason i think we're in a dark age is
because i have
taken seriously people's claims in a
bunch of different domains and ask and
keep asking them questions why they
believe what they believe because i find
their conclusions very unintuitive and
i'm trying to learn and i found that a
lot of times they're appealing to
ideas that seem highly dubious
and
they find their origins in the first
part of the 20th century across
disciplines so i'm trying to make sense
of some spectacular claims i'm sure
you've heard people
make some
incredible claim about reality and they
say well as we learn from quantum
mechanics things can be in a mutually
exclusive state at the same time
what does that mean that's a shocking
claim so you look into it and you look
into me go okay well there's this thing
called the copenhagen interpretation
that was established blah blah blah
same thing happens in mathematics i
don't know if you know
how familiar are with some of these
concepts but there's this notion of the
infinite set in mathematics the idea
that there is a set of numbers which is
infinite in size that there are
infinitary processes that can be
completed
it's a shocking claim interesting so you
investigate investigate you find okay a
lot of these ideas were established the
same general time period and so i
started to see
patterns of really bad ideas at present
seeming to have their origins at around
the same time period i'm going to put it
somewhere around 1880
to somewhere around 1950. a lot was
happening at that time so in terms of
ideas
uh i for me this may be incorrect i
might there's there's one exception
where this might the story might go back
further but let's just say it starts at
roughly 1880 1880
the reason we had a bunch of uh uh
bad ideas established around then is
because for the previous
few thousand years
our mathematics was more or less built
on concepts that came from euclidean
geometry
and
uh it was fashionable to think a lot of
people have thought throughout history
that euclidean geometry was
was the same thing as geometry there is
one geometry it is euclidean geometry
and
why uh um are advanced mathematical
ideas get their justification through
euclidean geometry well what happened
around this time period was the
development of non-euclidean geometries
which a lot of people said okay well if
there are non-euclidean geometries what
actually is the foundations of math we
assumed it was euclidean geometry which
is based in self-evident principles
self-evident axioms that anybody can
use and discover and see why the
conclusions follow but if there are
non-euclidean geometries maybe
we need a different foundation for math
so there was a this is not just my
opinion
there was a let's call it a formal
academic crisis around the foundations
of mathematics that was taking place
roughly from yeah 1880 to like the 19
yeah through the 1940s i think is fair
to say
now a lot of those conversations weren't
ended correctly like the the questions
weren't answered
you know people asking the questions
sort of died out they had different
schools of thought the school of thought
that wound up winning
didn't have good philosophical answers
and in fact in practice was kind of
anti-philosophical said stop asking the
questions and then we don't have
problems finding answers
something very similar happened in
physics
where you had a revolution in
multiple revolutions at the beginning of
the 20th century you had the development
of relativity which was which is a
mind-blowing idea to think that gravity
is
something that comes from the structure
of space-time
what the heck that means that's that's a
shocking idea and then shortly after
that you have the development of quantum
mechanics which
among other things one interpretation of
quantum mechanics called the copenhagen
interpretation says that there is no
such thing as a observation independent
reality
observation measurement independent
reality so we can't talk about nature in
some state outside of what is being
measured that's a shocking claim if
that's true that is an absolutely
mind-blowing claim
and i think it turns out to be false
and
and so uh if you
have deep conversations with people who
have uh sometimes wild sounding ideas
you would be shocked to find how many of
their wild ideas
are somehow justified in
uh either
the physics and the copenhagen
interpretation oh reality is
contradictory so therefore i can be
contradictory or even in concepts in
mathematics
now i have had multiple conversations
recorded on my podcast with professors
going around
trying to root out the source of a lot
of these bad ideas
and i have had people tell me on my show
that they've given me examples of
existent logical
contradictions uh
one of them was uh the infinite set
this this i i spoke with a philosopher
at columbia or it was a philosopher of
mathematics
and he's and we were talking about
whether or not there could be logical
contradictions because that's a shocking
claim if there are and he said oh yeah
there are logical contradictions like
for example the infinite sets kind of a
logical contradiction now he was saying
the infinite set is a contradictory
concept
in defense of it which is an interesting
position to take i was just mind blown
that that somebody would say that with a
straight face
there was in fact a whole school of
thoughts
called the dilethius school which says
there are actually existing logical
contradictions uh you can there's a
couple examples like the liars paradox
this sentence is false the way that they
try to handle the liar's paradox is by
saying it is true and false at the same
time whatever that means to sort of
explode logic to try to defend uh the
existence of a real paradox so anyway
i'm i'm examined i'm examining bad ideas
and i find myself
i keep coming to people keep appealing
to the ideas that were established
around the turn of 20th century
so and then i look at those ideas and i
go okay well there were there was some
prominent people
that came up with copenhagen
interpretation yields boar for example
there were some notable dissidents
uh einstein would be an example of
somebody who who's notorious for
rejecting some of the more wild
implications of copenhagen
interpretation
and einstein made better arguments but
niels bohr won out
so the same thing happened in uh in
mathematics around the same time you had
different schools of thought the
logistics the former the formalists and
the intuitionists formalists went out
but better ideas in my estimation were
were made by the other schools the
logicists who said that mathematics is
an extension of logic that's where
mathematical truth comes from is logic
the intuition it said well there is not
necessarily objective truth in
mathematics mathematics is all
constructed in the mind the objects of
mathematics are objects in our mind and
i think there's they have some aspect of
the truth
but anyway the the worst position of all
was the formalist and they said listen
uh we what we have to do is explicitly
strip meaning out of mathematics
we have
powerful structures of math that allow
us to
explain something in the world we can
use the math we can apply the math but
when you start asking the philosophical
questions we don't have we run into
paradoxes so stop asking them
so i see that as well that's a very big
problem now you also had in the early
20th century you had uh
uh
economic and political revolutions at
the same time
so you had you know communist
revolutions you had in that time period
in that 70 years you had two world wars
that was sort of uh you know world
defining world shaping you had the
establishment you know the latter half
the at the 19th century you had you know
the germ theory of disease was taking
off what was was being developed um you
had keynesianism was in the 1930s like i
said so the reason i'm i am
seeing that
my best explanation for the dark age
that we're in when you
if you were to peer into the mind of the
believers of really bad ideas that seem
to say really silly things all the time
and you were to try to figure out where
those ideas come from
i'm seeing tons of connections to that
70-year time period from 1880 to 1950
where it was tumultuous intellectually
as well as you know historically and
politically electrification was
happening you know there's a lot going
on then okay so that's the that's the
version yeah i think you've put some
things together for me that i did not
understand and they've
touched on another set of concepts i
didn't realize was nearby
so heather and i were professors for 15
years
and we became quite compelled that one
of the biggest obstacles to successful
education
was
the remoteness
of
physical reality
to
students and in specific we started
assigning students
to teach themselves things
where success or failure was unambiguous
and did not require anyone to tell you
whether you had succeeded or failed
right in other words if you set out to
build a tower and it falls down you
can't pretend you know you could lie to
yourself i guess but the point is it's
obvious it fell down if you're trying to
fix an engine and it doesn't start you
didn't fix it
um so
the reason that that's important is that
in an environment where everything is
socially mediated where you know that
you understood the biology because the
person at the front of the room who is
the biologist told you you understood it
right that's very risky because the
person at the front of the room doesn't
understand biology themselves then
you'll you'll do more harm in learning
what they think than if you learn
nothing right so
here's the question
our
technology progresses
to the point that what we think we
understand is no longer checkable
by very many people
right
i haven't looked deeply into the
machinery of
cells physically right i've seen major
organelles but i can't do very much to
check all of the things that i'm told
about cellular biology i have to take
the cellular biologist word for it
and my point is not that they're wrong
i'm sure they're wrong in some ways i'm
sure they're right in other ways
but the point is
once
you're looking at things that are
sufficiently small that you need
high-tech
mechanisms to allow you any insight into
what's there at all you're now running
new risks that what you're being told is
true isn't true and that your intuition
that can't be true because it's not what
i've seen you know when i've looked into
cells i haven't seen that price well you
haven't looked into cells right so
i guess the question is is is the thing
that you're detecting that early date
the result of the fact that across
discipline after discipline we crossed a
threshold where it was impossible for
most of the people in the discipline to
assess for themselves is this car is
this descartes nightmare
i think this is a small part of it okay
the reason i say that is because the
when you actually engage with the ideas
that were being discussed even if
they're abstract ideas
in some circumstances you don't need the
empirical verification i think what
you're saying is critically important
for
even making predictions if you can find
a discipline which is more connected to
real world feedback you are going to
find a discipline that has better
quality ideas than one which has no real
real world feedback this is true also in
the martial arts it's true everywhere
but
when i look at the
debate between
niels bohr
and einstein
i don't see something that can only be
resolved empirically there are there are
there are trivial conceptual errors that
are that are made
that still did not seem to change the
the social influence let's say of the
the wielders of the bad ideas
i'm not
i think i'm making a slightly more
subtle point than that okay it's not
it's again a taking the safety off the
gun issue it's not that as soon as
people can't check
that the rate of errors goes way up
it's that as soon as people can't check
the likelihood of important errors being
caught goes down and the degree to which
a persuasive person who is incorrect
continues to have influence goes up
and so i guess the point is
nature bats last
the world
is the arbiter of whether a scientific
or the universe is the arbiter of
whether a scientific idea is correct or
not based on predictive power of that
concept
and the degree to which we are taking
people's word for what has been
established or falsified
is now
um
overwhelming
that is definitely going on
but i'll i'll still i'll still push back
here so in the in the what you've just
articulated
it sounds like you would say correct me
if i'm wrong because maybe this is where
we have a disagreement it sounds like
you would say something like
if reality if a empirical experiment
could
demonstrate
that
one idea is a lot better than another
idea
that
that is sufficient to have the better
idea when out in the short run
um
you know there's a lot built into
what exactly we're using but you know
in the long run
predictive power is
the only tool
we have
for assessing the relative merit of
competing ideas in the short run though
because because in the in the grand
scheme of things we're type we're
talking about you know the 20th century
this is the short run it sounds like
it sounds like what you're saying is if
uh
if we had
a way to
simply test whether or not a particular
theory was true or false that that would
itself
solve a lot of these problems because
the assumption is
the academics would
recognize when a idea has been
invalidated
no i'm saying geez i don't know how to
convey it but imagine for a second that
there was a planet
that you were going to become expert you
and 50 other students were going to
become expert
on
the
social goings on on a planet that you
couldn't
visit or watch directly
and basically how were you going to
become expert on this well different
people who had been there
were going to come into the room and
they were going to tell you what they'd
seen and you were going to build a model
of the behavior of the creatures on this
other planet based on their observations
and my point is if you would directly
observe that planet
came in who was a fool
you might detect actually you know what
i really that's not what i saw i think
that person i'm not gonna
put a big asterisk on everything that
person says because i'm not sure they
know what they're doing right but
in this other landscape you might think
well that person has the fancier degree
the longer publication record um they
speak more persuasively and so the point
is the errors that get in
stick at a level that they should not so
it's something like
the facts of the experience
of one practitioner
are not then experienced by
another right and i
look i'm not a philosopher but my
understanding is this is kind of what
drove descartes crazy was when he
realized that um the fraction of what he
was supposedly what he fractured the
fraction of what he knew
that he was taking on someone else's
authority the danger was immense now
maybe the danger wasn't as big as he
thought because the number of things
that have to be true for lots of people
who have done the work to be wrong
simultaneously
you know it's unlikely but then it
becomes true at the beginning of the
20th century when we're dealing with
things that require
high technology to detect
and so you see i think that is part of
it but but the the aspect that i would
emphasize
is
that
it is
it is not the case that it would take
sophisticated equipment and technology
to figure out that a lot of these
paradigmatic ideas are wrong oh i
totally agree with this and this is the
thing i don't
get when you do look at these ideas and
you discover you know look in my field
right the idea
that there is only one species
per niche that two species cannot stably
co-exist in a niche
indefinitely one is always superior
competitively and it's driving the
inferior one to extinction right
i get how you could see that if you live
in the temperate zone nobody who's been
to the tropics could believe that and
it's unfalsifiable because
to the extent that you have 300 trees
doing approximately the same thing in
the same place you can always argue that
well they are competitively distinct as
saplings or blah blah blah anyway it's a
wrong idea that persists because it sort
of sounds intuitively like it ought to
be true and people haven't spotted why
it's false um
it's not
that any biologist is unaware
of the number of species of tree doing
identical things on the mainland
tropical forest it's that they don't
trust
their own understanding well enough to
call [ __ ] okay that that is big
i don't exactly know what's going on
there but that
is a pattern that is across disciplines
and it's weird because some of these
ideas are
in the open spoken about
explicitly and yet there's a disconnect
between
a recognition of an idea being wrong and
a changing of the theory or the culture
around that idea and i don't understand
what's going on there but i've seen it a
bunch of times
well again
let's let's steel man
people who do
this there are lots of ideas that are
not right
but aren't so i wanted to draw a
distinction between
bad ideas that are just simply wrong
and consequentially bad ideas that is to
say ones that cause you to become dumber
if you assume they're true like
um i think the idea of muscle memory
is pretty benign
it's wrong there is no muscle memory but
there's something that works enough like
it that for most people's purposes if
you just believe that there's muscle
memory and your muscles get good at
doing certain things it's good enough
right it's not a consequentially bad
idea except maybe
in some
narrow disciplines yeah but my point
would be if you were to take every
idea in biology that wasn't quite right
and throw it out
you'd have almost nothing to say because
they're all approximate
right we don't know biology that well
yet we're still new at this and so
there's a resistance i don't i
personally even the stuff that i'm using
i don't want somebody nitpicking all of
the things that i say and throwing them
out on the basis that they're imprecise
because the point is they're good enough
i'm aware that they're not precise and
if i threw out everything that was in
precise i'd have nothing that is the
steel man version yes that's the steel
man version yes but then the point is
once you buy yourself license not to
throw out a wrong idea because it's good
enough for the purposes that you're
using it for and you're keeping track of
its imprecision then you now have
license to lie and to protect your
career and all of these other things and
people use that and so then you get
generations of students that you know
can't figure out which way is up
yes so
this is this is really fascinating and
i have seen
that pattern repeated many many times
and and i would just say describing from
the outside as not an academic
there seems to be
a
some percentage
of
professional intellectuals
know
that the stories that they tell and have
been told are strictly speaking faults
so you see this in mathematics all the
time like you're working within a
certain set of axioms
but the axioms might not be true
but then
there's another set of people maybe
students maybe it's the way that
students get taught i'm not sure
that think that the
cherished starting concepts of the
discipline or the
the idea
are
actually true
and we're sort of building from these
rock solid assumptions
so that so with i've seen this where
i'll talk to one mathematician and he's
like is definitely the case that x y and
z because z of c set theory is
the the one that we're all going to just
you know defend as true and you talk to
others
and they're like oh yeah well that's
just convention yeah i mean you can have
you know there are certain conclusions
you get from those assumptions and you
have different assumptions and you get
different conclusions so and i don't i
don't yet quite understand
what
how this is getting lost in translation
and it seems to be a big problem because
i've also noticed that people who write
most passionately and try to do to you
know harm other people's reputations are
those who are the in the believer
category where they think they're being
personally assaulted when their
cherished ideas are being entertained as
being false those seem to be the people
that are in this middle ground between
ideas and and like
the general public this is like in the
media sphere and i don't know i don't
know if you've seen that same pattern oh
100 yeah the foot soldiers are the true
believers in ideas yeah are
imprecise at best
um i was gonna say though that i think
all of this is a consequence of that
diminishing returns piece that i was
discussing with you because of the way
generations of academics happen right so
if early evolutionary biologists
came up with the idea
that
reproductive success
was
the
the core of um
fitness
and then they teach their students that
and their students are like yeah
reproductive success you know fitness
right as if they're the same thing
and that works really great because most
of the time they're really closely
correlated right so the point is oh this
is fantastically productive if we just
assume that they're the same thing we
you know papers galore and then the
point is for every puzzle where they're
not the same thing you're now a confused
fool you don't know what happened
because you don't remember that your
ancestors made that assumption so you
don't know how to unmake it you don't
even think it is an assumption you think
they're synonymous exactly right
and
and so the problem is the people who
remember that they cheated are dead
yeah their students took it as gospel
and now we're like
hunting around in the dark for something
really obvious that the ancestor would
have been like oh yeah that was just
approximately this is another this is
another thing i haven't written about
yet but this is right on you're hitting
the nail right on the head it also seems
to be as bad as so many thinkers are
that
sometimes the originators of
useful concepts were perfectly aware
of the limitations of their theory
einstein was like this he called his own
theory potentially a castle in the sky
my favorite example is the inventor of
the imaginary numbers the square root of
negative one this was in like the 17th
century or something so he came up with
this concept it solves some math
problems and he used the term
this is a useful fiction like when you
really sit down and think about the
square root of negative one how does
that it doesn't make a lot of sense but
i said listen it's a useful fiction
incorporated and then you can solve some
math problems
over time now we have developed a
metaphysics about imaginary numbers and
the complex plane and all these all of
these concepts that are built on
on other concepts that aren't totally
sorted out that even the originator of
those ideas would have known are not
sorted out yeah and i must tell you i
mean you know uh
i nobody knows the flaws and the
imprecisions in my work better than me
right i'd be fooled to do the work and
not have figured out where the places
that i'm you know if it's going to fail
it's going to fail thereby right right
you would do that but the point is you
can imagine
how you know that
gets lost in conveying it and that
anybody who's like oh that's a great
idea
doesn't realize
you should be a little cautious about
that piece that's spackle you know that
is a huge piece of the puzzle that that
right that idea of this subtlety being
totally lost on future generations and
then that the subtle and then the the
tentative uh ideas becoming dogma that
happens everywhere every and i i keep
coming back to mathematics that's one of
my pet subjects i've been researching of
late there mathematics is shot
throughout with conventions conventions
conventions and somebody made a decision
somewhere it's okay we'll just do it
this way i'm not exactly sure but look
we get to a good you know just get in
the car and we're going to arrive at the
destination and stop asking questions
and then those conventions turn into
laws of the universe and it's like if
you have a
a secondary
you know if you think okay well what
exactly does this concept mean they go
what are you talking about you can't do
this this you're talking about essential
you know ideas in mathematics this is
not the thing you apply critical
thinking and skepticism too
right
um which then
um
[Music]
creates
the following dynamic and i know you're
going to have to go maybe we pick this
conversation up sooner rather than later
but
a stuck field
is very easy to beat
right it's not hard to out-think a field
that's talking itself in circles
however
when you do that
it is not interested in hearing about it
and in fact it treats you like
you're
an absolute crank right yep yep and
there's nothing you can do to beat this
so this is one thing i tell students
when they now ask me you know i'm really
interested in biology what should i do
and it's like look you got to decide
whether you want to succeed in that
field or you really like the subject
matter right you really like the subject
matter it's a great era because the
field isn't making any progress right
you can pick your puzzle you can have
way more than your share right
but
don't expect anybody to listen to you
you know that's my favorite
mathematician who i think is doing
incredibly important work his name is
norman wildberger and um he's a canadian
but he was teaching in australia for
most of his career and he just retired
and he's got he's putting his ideas
online and he talks about this all the
time where he'll get people writing in
saying oh i'm really interested in your
approach to math this makes a lot more
sense and he says listen
go at it but
maybe as an amateur maybe just
resign yourself to doing math as an
amateur and you're probably not going to
get the prestige if you're not willing
to play the game that the professionals
are playing
yeah it's actually uh i i can't remember
whether we had started
the podcast or not but it's one of the
reasons i'm so fascinated by
your
lack of the usual pedigree for talking
about the things that you're talking
about you're obviously extremely
clear-headed and insightful and and
creative
um
uh and it does not as somebody who has
seen the dysfunction and has watched it
spread and has now seen it in a couple
different fields on several different
topics
the idea that somebody that you
you know
yes you have to be smart and insightful
and creative to do it but
you're gonna have to have
just a gargantuan helping of
independence in order to see past the
nonsense that's a whole another that's a
whole nother can of worms uh the the
influence of
psychology the relationship between
psychological features and
uh ideas is a fascinating one and i'm
seeing more and more it is almost as if
academia is a
selection mechanism for psychological
traits
that has very
very little uh
uh correlation between
high quality ideas or i should say it
has an inverse correlation with
independent ideas because they're they
seem and and maybe it's because they're
you know psychologically they're they're
malnourished you know i i don't exactly
know what's going on but um well let's
put it this way i think you're being
delicate and
academia
selects for cowardice
yeah it absolutely selects for cowardice
and um
tenure is supposed to correct for that
but it's too late in the process too
um and this not only accounts
for the unwillingness of people to call
out the obvious nonsense in their own
fields but it also accounts for the
vulnerability of those fields to
invasion by woke nonsense yes okay so i
i got to say one more thing just because
this is funny and uh all right i have a
little bit of context all right um
early on several years ago when i was
doing this before i really became before
like i started saying outrageous things
in multiple disciplines it was just
outrageous things in a few disciplines i
was getting a lot of flack from
academics
and uh one of the f that i was getting
is they said steve you must think you
are a genius if you're right you must be
a genius
and i said no no
i have a much more insulting uh way to
frame this
my claim is that it does not take a
genius to figure out that some of these
ideas that you think are high quality
are low quality and i mean that
truthfully if you said i know this
because i've had the experience i just
earlier this year i had a pair of uh
danish high school students or the
equivalent of high school students over
there and they somehow came across some
of my work on mathematics and they were
really intrigued by it they reached out
to me and uh
it was it was a cool experience i was
talking to them about some really cool
philosophical concepts about mathematics
and you could see the wheels were
spinning they were understanding oh this
makes so much more sense i knew my high
school person was you know the teacher
was incorrect
i said they were going to write a little
paper
on these better ideas i was like okay
this is not rocket science now if it
were rocket science wouldn't those
academics feel better about themselves
because they would say listen you can
criticize my ideas but only if you're a
super genius
if you're some shmo
as some self-educated guy on the
internet and you can accurately
criticize
cherished ideas well that is uh where do
you hide behind you know that that is a
much more devastating
situation to be in which i think is the
situation like if i have anything going
for me it's the independence and like i
have a healthy stable relationship that
isn't going anywhere i can say whatever
i want to say and that automatically
gives me you know i've got that in
spades which means
i i'm free to you know make a bunch of
outrageous conclusions and not not
terrified that it's going to destroy me
in any way
that that all that'll say i i'm i'm uh
i'm blessed
the intelligence thing i don't even
think that needs to enter in the
discussion
well i i used to have my own formulation
on this uh i used to tell students that
um mental horsepower is way overrated
way overrated if you have less mental
horsepower it will take you longer to
solve the problem yes still solve the
problem and you probably have enough
time
so i told them the three characteristics
that you need if you really want to do
the transcendent stuff
are audacity tenacity and veracity
right you have to care a lot about
what's true you have to be willing to
say things that will get you in a huge
amount of trouble
be willing to stick with the damn
puzzles right until they're actually
solved but those three things are
way more important than mental health
and i would go farther with the analogy
that just having horsepower
and no
understanding of what roads are no
understanding of traffic signals just
the ability to go fast is much more
likely to result in you driving off a
cliff and ending up in a ditch
than it is you arriving at this
particular destination you know on the
continent that you're on which
in my opinion is the case uh
intellectually speaking if you are if
you only have intelligence going for you
and you don't have you know wisdom or
judgment or philosophy or you're not in
the environment to
learn how to utilize your mental
horsepower i think you're ending up much
farther away from the truth
than
somebody who has you know
less intelligence
is thinking much slower has even just
dogmatically believed what their parents
told them that person is still going to
be closer to truth i think than somebody
with a horsepower going in the wrong
direction oh totally no it's like uh you
know
at the core of an engine are explosions
but if you think oh i know what i need i
need explosions
no you really might want to start with a
cylinder and a piston and you know
all right well this has been fantastic i
know you have to go i'm looking forward
to talking to you again and exploring
this
further but anyway it's um
always marvelous to run into people who
you've never heard of who um
have minds so full of fascinating and
obviously important stuff so
thanks brett it was a lovely
conversation thank you for inviting me
on
you're welcome really appreciate you and
uh keep up the good work
uh where can people find you again so i
met steve at steve-patterson.com and
it's probably worth uh mentioning i am
in the process of starting a research
institute called the natural philosophy
institute um i have a website napfi dot
org natpha.org
there's nothing on there it's just a
kind of a wait list i'm hoping right now
i'm finishing up a book project for a
client and once that's done hopefully
soon i'm going to transition sort of
full time into
producing more content professionally
and that'll be at natphi.org
all right awesome well it's been a
pleasure and uh see you next time great
thanks brad
[Music]
you